et rés tous ces événements que l'on va
vivre avec vous et bien sûr on attend
vos commentaires vos réactions vos
questions on est là pour y répondre
on va tout de suite allé à lille
retrouvez timothée d'hellemmes envoyé
spécial figaro live sur place bonjour
thimoté
[Musique]
bonjour un an vous êtes avec maxime
laurie on voit à côté john timsit
d'abord quelle est l'ambiance
au palais de le palais des congrès de
lille où va ce va se dérouler le meeting
l'équipe zemmour rome était annoncé
depuis plusieurs jours beaucoup
d'inscrits est ce que c'est le cas est
ce que il y a vous voyez la fluence
qu'ils ont annoncé qu'ils ont promis
qu'ils ont espéré
alors ici à lille grand palais
l'ambiance est en train de monter petit
à petit vincent la salle est en train de
se remplir on aperçoit quelques drapeaux
français on a entendu également les
premières sac la nation tout à l'heure
c'était aux alentours de 14h20 lorsque
le premier le premier clip de campagne a
été diffusée sur les huit écrans géants
déployé pour l'occasion vous entendez un
autre clip est en train d'être diffusée
derrière moi pas de chants entonnés par
les militants pour le moment du côté des
officiels nous avons aperçu et bien la
garde rapprochée d'eric zemmour antoine
diers ce que directeur adjoint de la
stratégie de campagne et quelques élus
guillaume pelletier et puis gilbert
collard le récent transfuge du
rassemblement national jérôme rivière
également pour rentrer dans le grand
palais de lille certains militants ont
attendu plus d'une heure dès notre
arrivée sur place à 11h45 déjà il ya un
50 mètres de queue après devant devant
le grand palais puis les portes ont été
ouvertes à 13 heures la salle ensuite
mis du temps à se remplir nous demandiez
gars il est lui militant a annoncé par
les équipes d'eric zemmour était
présente pour l'instant ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que la salle continue de
se remplir mais elle met du temps à se
remplir il ya un bon tiers de la salle
qui est encore vide alors qu'on est à 20
minutes après des débuts à redon du
début
du meeting les militants qui sont
présents attendent désormais le début
des interventions les premières
interventions sous d'annoncé pour 15h15
l'entrée d'eric zemmour elle devrait
intervenir à peu près vers 16h alors je
salue pendant que vous parlez d'arc qui
nous rejoint à qui il dit qu' il préfère
suivre le meeting sur le site du
candidat bien c'est votre droit dark ici
en tous les cas vous aurez l'occasion
d'avoir les informations vous venez
d'entendre de timothée d'hellemmes et
également on va y revenir dans un
instant l'éclairage d'un des meilleurs
politologue d'un des meilleurs
connaisseurs de la droite française on
va retrouver timothée d'hellemmes qui
est à côté de quelqu'un qui suit
particulièrement
cette campagne c'est john timsit du
service politique du figaro thimoté
c'est vous qui avez la main pour voir et
pour nous expliquer avec john quelles
vont être les enjeux et quelles sont les
coulisses de ce meeting
avec john key s'est arrêté quelques
minutes avant le début de son de son
reportage conserver ce politique du
figaro beau jour jeanne bonjour alors
john eric zemmour a communiqué hier sur
son compte twitter il a dit qu'il allait
faire un discours sur le pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui le pouvoir d'achat c'est pas
son thème de prédilection est-ce que
c'est pas d'ailleurs son talon d'achille
on sait que exe moore a bâti toute sa
précampagne et son début de campagne sur
la question de l'immigration de
l'identité de l'islam sur la question de
la survie de la civilisation
il il a voulu c'est vrai concurrence et
marine le pen sur ses propres segments
électoraux il a dépassé par sa droite
depuis depuis quelques mois et c'est
vrai qu'il a réussi à capter un bon gros
tiers de son électorat mais c'est vrai
que quand on parle avec des gens pas
forcément des gens qui sont dans le
milieu politique c'est vrai qu'il est
identifié beaucoup beaucoup plus eric
zemmour a cédé à cette thématique
régaliennes et - at-c à détecter matic
économique et donc c'est vrai que les
mots c'est qu'il a ce retard par rapport
à ma gueule marine le pen et donc il va
tenter au moins de rattraper une partie
de son retard avec un discours plus axé
sur le pouvoir d'achat sur le travail
voilà pour essayer de
de rattraper sa principale concurrente
sur les électeurs de marine le pen
justement lors de son précédent grand
meeting c'était la ville entière il ya
deux mois a visé cuisine elle est plutôt
aller chercher les électeurs des
républicains les déçus de eric ciotti
par exemple aujourd'hui il est sur les
terres du rassemblement national dans
les hautes france je rappelle que marine
le pen et celle des autres en ce qu'est
ce que qu'est ce qui se dit dans
l'entourage de campagne d'eric zemmour
est ce que qu'est-ce qui va dire à cet
électorat populaire à du rassemblement
national
c'est vrai comme vous l'avez dit que
quand on voit la sociologie électorale
qui votent pour eric zemmour c'est vrai
qu'il a beaucoup moins deux catégories
populaires que marine le pen lui il a
beaucoup beaucoup plus des catégories
supérieures en tout cas ce qu'on appelle
une sorte de bourgeoisie patriotes qui
le soutient et donc c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui les équipes tech demo
nous
la leur il va essayer de faire un
discours comme les classes d'âge peuvent
y aller avait pu le faire en deux en
2007 sur la question du travail du
mérite ou pouvoir d'achat surtout sur
ses terres du nord qui ont été beaucoup
marquée par la désindustrialisation par
les questions de chômage par les
questions de pouvoir d'achat et donc il
va être fait y il va essayer de corriger
un peu le tir de son argumentaire de
campagne et de et de s'intéresser
davantage à ses préoccupations que ce
qui leur a été fait jusqu alors un petit
mot john sur les échauffourées qui
émaillent certains déplacements vérité
se souvient de ces images très violentes
de avec cette altercation cette bagarre
générale avec sos racisme qu'est ce qui
se dit également à ce niveau là dans
l'est les équipes d'eric zemmour par
exemple sur ce meeting comment est-ce
qu'on appréhende cela alors j'ai pas
plus d'informations à vous donner à ce
moment là mais c'est vrai que si le
meeting evil parts avait été une grosse
démonstration de force c'est vrai que
les images des violences avaient fait un
petit peu tâche dans l'équipe et ça
avait entaché la
la force médiatique quelques arrêts
transmitting pour l'instant on est
plutôt calme mais bon à voir dans les
prochaines minutes de caussade et
dernière question de jeunes
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure de gilbert
collard de jérôme rivière de griots
politiques étaient présents il ya un nom
qui est sur toutes les lèvres
aujourd'hui c'est celui de marion
maréchal alors elle est ce qu'elle sera
là où ce sera pas là écoutez pour
l'instant je n'ai pas du tout que je ne
pense pas qu'elle sera là puisqu'elle
n'a pas encore officialisé ce monde sont
l'aliment et on ne sait pas si elle le
fera bien qu'elle hésite comme elle l'a
indiqué au ciss au figaro il ya une il
ya une petite semaine donc a priori elle
elle ne sera pas là mais on verra dans
les prochaines semaines
merci beaucoup
john voilà vincent pour cette analyse de
john timsit journaliste politique au
figaro je sais pas si vous vous en
rendez compte on a beaucoup de mal à
s'entendre il ya un petit peu d'ambiance
qui est en train de monter derrière en
tout cas les clips de campagne d'eric
zemmour continue d'être d'être diffusé
sur les huit écrans géants de la salle
merci beaucoup timothée effectivement on
le voit derrière vous on va y revenir et
merci beaucoup à john timsit qui va nous
raconter et bien sûr on attend avec
impatience le compte rendu de john sur
le site du figaro qui sera à découvrir
dans les minutes dans les oeufs dans les
minutes qui vont suivre la fin de cet
événement et la fin de ce meeting on l'a
on laisse jeunes travailler et puis on
va rester également avec avec timothy
avec timothée vous êtes nombreux à nous
rejoindre en tous les cas sur le chat du
figaro et en particulier sur également
sur le chat de youtube vous continuez je
salue notamment pardon je peux pas vous
citer tous mais vous êtes nombreux à na
andric
rtf qui nous rejoignent en ce moment
alors même un internaute qui s'appelle
études bâtiment et génie civil alors
entre les cas on attend le génie de vos
commentaires dans ce chat et au cours de
cet après midi certains internautes nous
reprochait justement de commenter cet
événement alors effectivement il sait
pas un événement brut qui a sans
commentaire on est là pour justement
éclairé décrypter et notamment avec je
vous le disais l'un des plus grands
meilleurs connaisseurs de la droite
guillaume bernard
professeur maître de conférences de lys
s à la roche sur yon politologue et
historien du droit et surtout auteur de
ce livre livre de référence la guerre à
droite aura bien lieu guillaume on y est
oui bonjour vincent et bonjour aux
internautes oui on y est absolument
c'était inéluctable parce que il y avait
une répartition entre différentes forces
politiques différentes organisations
politiques qui étaient pour certaines
incohérente en leur sein même et on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui par exemple heller
essaye de tenir un grand écart entre une
position plutôt au centre et une
position un peu droitière pour éviter
que trop d'électeurs naïve air et mourou
le pen c'était inéluctable aussi parce
que il y avait une on va dire ça
simplement une droitisation de
l'électorat et en particulier du peuple
de droite qui ne supportaient plus 10
supportait de moins en moins la
distorsion entre le fait que les élus
les caciques les chefs des partis
politiques de droite étaient sur des
positions somme toute assez mitigé alors
que l'électorat lui était se radicaliser
de plus en plus donc la distorsion ces
différentes distorsion la
conduisait inéluctablement à ce qu'il y
ait une recomposition de la vie
politique et en particulier de ceux qui
est à droite du spectre politique cette
recomposition elle est en cours elle
n'est pas encore terminée
mais elle est en cours et elle devient
là pour le coup absolument évidente avec
évidemment notamment l'émergence d'eric
zemmour sur la scène politique la
création de son parti politique et puis
il faut bien le dire une une
véritable réussite je ne sais pas du
tout si eric zemmour sera serré que
zemmour comme il le souhaite sera au
deuxième tour de la présidentielle
enfin le simple fait d'avoir engrangé 80
mille adhérents semble-t-il en quelques
semaines c'était évidemment en termes de
chiffres une véritable réussite quand on
sait que l air a aujourd'hui il
revendique aujourd'hui environ cent
cinquante mille adhérents ou que le
front national en a environ 30 à 40
risle il ya quelque chose de frappant
quand on relit votre livre qui est paru
juste avant les précédentes élections
présidentielles ça et même avant la
primaire des verts avant la laitue
nerveux avant la primaire a
effectivement octobre 2016
il ya quelque chose d'assez frappant
c'est que dès
cette époque
vous évoqué la possibilité d'une
candidature de règlement oui c'est vrai
je fais partie de ceux qui ont pensé que
parent je dirais l'habilité verbal qu'il
avait par sa présence médiatique et bien
il faisait partie des gens qui étaient
susceptibles de pouvoir recomposer la
droite est rassemblée alors je ne suis
pas encore une fois certains qu'ils
puissent véritablement et aboutir je
suppose que tout au long de l'après midi
on va pouvoir en discuter quant à la
stratégie qu'il a mise en place depuis
qu'il est candidat depuis quelques
semaines mais pour autant il est certain
que avec des personnalités comme marion
maréchal comme jean frédéric poisson
comme si libre de villiers il avait je
dirais un pedigree il avait une identité
politique qui leur permettait
d'envisager de faire une recomposition
politique et c'est vrai j'ai évoqué le
cas de le cas d'eric zemmour à cette
époque là il est bien évident que on
n'était pas certain du tout qu'il soit
capable de se transformer en orateurs
politiques dans un meeting il était un
bon débatteur sur les plateaux télé mais
est-ce qu'il serait un bon candidat et
notamment un bon orateur dans les
meetings ça ça n'était pas certain il
semblerait que pour ce qui est de cet
aspect là des choses il a réussi son
pari alors on va continuer à suivre ça
justement et de voir quelles sont les
autres défis pour eric zemmour au cours
avec ce meeting qui se tient à lille où
on va retrouver à timothée d'hellemmes
si timothée encore avec nous ce qui nous
en parle oui il nous entend avec la
caméra de maxime l'oeil
timothée vous
en vous en vous voyant et en voyant ce
qui se passe derrière vous je vous
répondais à cet internaute qui dit il ya
quand même beaucoup de chaises vides
oui tout à fait vincent c'est ce que je
suis ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure il ya beaucoup de chaises vides
je dirais que c'est à peu près c'est
difficile à juger mais je dirais à peu
près un tiers de la salle qui n'est
qu'ils n'aient pas qui n'est pas remplie
à un gros tiers même vous le voyez sur
ces images de deux maximes glory en fait
voilà sur ce toutou le carla sur la
gauche de de la salle n'est n'est pas du
tout n'est pas du tout empli quand on
s'avance devant évidemment on sent une
certaine ferveur chez chez les militants
mais pour l'instant la salle est loin
d'être d'être rempli quelques militants
sont encore en train de pénétrer dans la
salle on verra tout à l'heure si si la
salle fini par être remplies même si
c'est vrai que pour l'instant c'est loin
d'être le cas on parlait tout à l'heure
effectivement de tension en tout cas de
contrôle manifeste de
contre-manifestations et de
contre-manifestants nos confrères je ne
sais plus si c'est bfm ou c'est nous
tout à l'heure mais disait qu'il y avait
eu quelques échauffourées est ce que
vous avez observé
des tensions particulières
alors moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que justement on a été assez frappés par
le calme qui pouvait y avoir devant le
grand palais de lille lorsque nous
sommes arrivés je vous le disais tout à
l'heure vers 11h45 on est on est rentré
dans la salle à 13 heures donc on a
passé une petite heure devant le grand
palais il y avait une grande grande que
c'était à peu près 50 m à 11h45 depuis
ça s'est petit à petit élargie jusqu'à
13 heures où il y avait vraiment un
grand grand nombre de personnes que de
plusieurs centaines de mètres est en
tout cas voilà beaucoup de calme
absolument aucun heurt a déclaré devant
le grand palais pour ce qui est du
centre ville de lille je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas on n'a pas de pad
honneur à ce niveau là un gros
dispositif de policiers il y avait une
vingtaine de cars de crs mais nous en
tout cas pas de violences constaté ni à
l'extérieur ni à l'intérieur pour
l'instant quel est le cannet le
programme accès limité de l'après midi à
vivre
oui alors justement voilà donc là on est
en train de se rapprocher et et bien de
la tribune avec avec ses images de
maxime laurie vous voyez là ça y est
c'est assez c'est plus garni lorsqu on
s'approche de la de la tribune est pour
l'instant et bien c'est un questionnaire
qui est en train d'être diffusé sur les
sur les écrans géants avec des dégâts
bola le questionnaire se termine à
l'instant avec des questions de type
pensez vous qu eric zemmour est il
plutôt lève tôt ou lève tard pensez vous
qu eric zemmour et à une question sur la
bière est ce qu'ils aiment la bière
voilà et les militants qui peuvent en
fait vous les voyez sur leur portable
qui peuvent en fait répondre à ces
questions via l'application sur le site
de d'eric zemmour voilà le questionnaire
qui vient à l'instant de se terminer
et les interventions qui devrait pas
trop tarder à commencer maintenant elles
sont prévues pour pour 15h15
15h15 et effectivement vous avez raison
d'être sur le site du figaro si vous
voulez suivre cet événement parce que
pour l'instant on est pour l'instant le
seul un des seuls endroits où on a
justement l'événement un peu plus en
longueur et
commenter je vous le disais par
guillaume bernard auteur de la guerre à
droite aura bien lieu on continue de
suivre bien sûr avec vous timothée s'il
y a des militants s'il y a des également
des responsables de la campagne d'eric
zemmour des organisateurs de ce meeting
eh bien vous nous appelez vous nous fait
signe et on revient bien sûr avec vous
et notamment pour avoir vos réponses aux
questions des journalistes alors rtf par
exemple peut-être vous allez pouvoir
nous répondre nous dit il reste à peine
500 places la salle est blindée alors
est ce que vous avez
l'impression est ce que ce que vous
voyez montre que c'est une salle
reprendre l'expression de cet internaute
blindés
alors là pour l'instant timothée
ben arfa faire la réponse tout de suite
on reposera la question qu'on peut dire
quel plaisir ce qu'on peut dit guillaume
que l'on peut dire sur la question des
meetings c'est à quoi cela sert ça sert
à deux choses ça sert d'abord à
galvaniser les troupes ça sert à
mobiliser les militants à les leur
donner des arguments est ce qu'ils se
rencontrent à ce qui se montent le
bourrichon si vous me permettez
l'expression
un peu familière ensemble et puis ça
sert à une deuxième chose et c'est là où
peut-être le fait que si la salle n'est
pas autant rempli qu'il ne l'avait
espéré
ça pourrait avoir un impact ça sert tout
simplement faire des images c'est à dire
que ça sert à décoincer un certain
nombre de personnes qui pourraient être
tentés de voter pour le candidat en
question eric zemmour ou n'importe quel
autre un ce que je dis là s'applique à
tous les candidats qui est qui pourrait
se dire là si les salles sont autant
rempli s'il ya autant de gens qui sont
prêtes autant de personnes qui sont
prêtes à aller soutenir ce candidat là
c'est que mon intuition ma tendance ma
pente eh ben elle n'est pas si tu dirais
idiote que cela donc c'est vrai que une
salle qui seraient trop grande et donc
pas assez rempli en particulier lorsque
eric zemmour va dans le nord là où le
front national le rassemblement national
fait de très gros scores là
effectivement ça pourrait être
contre-productif contre-productif pour
lui alors françois nous dit il ya
beaucoup de monde les gens sont
agglutinés devant merci de montrer la
réalité non pas des chaises vides alors
vous voyez françois les images en ce
moment tous les cas qu'on vous montre
sont une partie de la réalité est qu'on
ne voit pas de chaise vide mais si vous
me dites qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
agglutinés dit nous vous êtes ce que
vous êtes à l'intérieur de la salle est
ce que vous êtes à l'extérieur de la
salle où vous êtes ailleurs un autre
internaute nous dit il ya qu à voir sur
le
quand youtube d'eric zemmour pour vous
ça cieux pour voir et se donner à voir
une idée du monde qu'il peut y avoir là
effectivement il ya beaucoup de monde
sur le compte youtube d'eric zemmour
pour l'instant il n'ya pas les des
images du meeting et on voit à l'instant
justement le questionnaire dont nous
parlait
timothée le questionnaire qui est posée
est envoyée aux militants
alors justement le
meeting en tout cas les images plus
officielle devrait également être nous
parvenir également et on les mettra dans
les mixera également avec celles qui
nous parviennent du palais de lille
grand palais où se déroule ce meeting un
des enjeux vous le disiez également
en tous les cas vous l'évoquiez en creux
guillaume c'est de se retrouver sur les
terres de marine le pen alors c'est le
nord des terres de marine le pen
exactement c'est pas de calais oui le
député de la circonscription de hénin
beaumont est ce que c'est quel est le
qu'elle doit être selon vous la
l'objectif d'eric zemmour sur ce terrain
là cet après midi il est certain si vous
me permettez juste de remonter un tout
petit peu le fil pour faire comprendre à
nos auditeurs je dirais pourquoi vous me
posez cette question là c'est un que je
prends deux internautes et bien en fait
aujourd'hui eric zemmour est crédité
d'environ 14% des intentions de vote il
faut savoir qu évidemment pour eric
zemmour les instituts de sondage ont des
difficultés à mesurer son impact réel
parce que tout simplement
les instituts de sondages ne dispose pas
du der heede du comparatif entre ce
qu'un sondage donne avec ce qui est
véritablement leurs résultats dans une
élection dont qu'il ne puisse qu'eric
zemmour et pour la première fois
candidat il n'y a pas la capacité à
redresser les résultats par rapport à
aux données brutes bien mais enfin les
et véronique rassoul de bakbone
consulting hier sur figaro live et c'est
toujours l'inde et l'une des difficultés
ça a été peut-être l'un des problèmes
également pour emmanuel macron en 2010
c'est pierre chenal quand même un peu
sous-estimé la performance qu'il allait
faire au premier tour absolument donc ça
c'est le premier point après si on admet
que malgré les marges d'erreur malgré
cette difficulté là eric zemmour est
entre 12 et 14 qu'est ce que c'est que
ces 12 à 14% d'intentions de vote c'est
pour dire les choses de manière un peu
caricaturale et bien les huit et demi
pour cent de françois-xavier bellamy aux
européennes c'est à dire une partie de
l'électorat et l'eire qui est plutôt
conservateur c'est quelques points que
eric zemmour a grappillé à nicolas
dupont aignan et ses quelques points 3 à
4 points qu'il a pris à marine le pen
nicolas dupont aignan qui est quand même
lui-même candidat est en passe de voir
toutes ces signes est d'avoir ces
signatures mais il a baissé de quasiment
la moitié de ses intentions de vote
depuis depuis quelques mois alors
puisqu'il était à 5 il est donné entre 2
et 3 et donc on peut raisonnablement
penser que ces électeurs là ont basculé
de nicolas dupont aignan a à eric
zemmour alors il est certain que les
électeurs du front national que enfin
décidément je n'y arriverai pas du
rassemblement national qui eric zemmour
a capté qu'est ce que c'est ce sont les
électeurs qui ont été déçus de la
prestation de marine le pen en 2017 lors
du débat du second tour ce sont les
catégories sociales les plus élevées de
l'électorat du front national du
rassemblement national et disons le
aussi ce sont les laits purger ou disons
ceux qui ont été évincés du
rassemblement national par marine le pen
et son équipe et donc il est certain que
l'électorat populaire du rassemblement
national n'est pour l'instant pas du
tout capté par eric zemmour pour deux
raisons 1 l'électorat populaire ne
s'intéressent pas encore complètement à
la campagne il n'ya que environ 52 à 53
% des français qui s'intéressent à la
campagne électorale de cette année donc
ça veut dire que et bien il ya toute une
partie de l'électorat français qu'il
soit n'a pas l'intention d'aller voter
soit ne s'y intéressent pas et ça fait
plutôt partie ce sont plutôt les
catégories populaires et puis
deuxièmement ça veut dire que les
catégories populaires ne sont pas encore
séduite par eric zemmour est donc c'est
sans doute cela qu'il essaye de faire
parce que et c'est toute l'ambiguïté de
la stratégie d'eric zemmour il proclame
le fait de dire qu'il fait l'union des
droites mais on a quand même plutôt
l'impression que son objectif en ce
moment c'est d'essayer de se substituer
à marine le pen plus que de faire
l'union des droites donc là un des
enjeux des semaines qui vont venir dès
qu'ils vont venir et notamment du
meeting d'aujourd'hui c'est la question
de savoir est ce qu'il va élargir le
spectre politique de la droite ou est-ce
qu'il va simplement cherché à se
substituer à marie lebel
on va retourner à l'est la lille grand
palais où se trouve donc l'équipe 2
figaro live est retrouvé timothée
d'hellemmes qui se trouve avec un
militant
absolument vincent avec un militant
d'eric zemmour qui est venu de la région
de reims de la banlieue de reims ce
matin pour pour ce meeting bonjour
bonjour est ce que c'est la première
fois que vous assistez un meeting d'eric
zemmour déjà c'est la première fois que
j'assiste un métier une d'eric zemmour
alors pourquoi est ce que vous avez
décidé de vous rendre à lille
aujourd'hui pour ce meeting a déjà pour
apporter mon soutien parmi les 7000
personnes est si présent et puis
et puis après apporter aussi autour de
mon entourage quand je rentrerai chez
moi ce que j'ai entendu directement sur
l'économie surtout
eric zemmour c'est quelqu'un que vous
suis depuis longtemps que vous supportez
depuis longtemps bien c'est un récent
soutien si on veut c'est un récent
soutien enfin déjà par l'info sur ces
news dont je le suivais et puis après la
suite aux tempêtes qu'est ce qui vous a
séduit alors chez les ch et les
propositions du candidat de reconquête
des gens un discours clair audible c'est
pour moi c'est très important et parle
de ruralité je suis la ruralité donc je
pense qu'il faut beaucoup de candidats
qui parle de ruralité et nous sommes
quand même depuis pas mal d'années les
oubliés de la ruralité et c'est ce qui
m'a plu entre autres
aujourd'hui eric zemmour a dit qu'il
allait faire un discours sur le pouvoir
d'achat c'est pas du tout son thème de
prédilection c'est plutôt quelqu'un qui
parle d'identité qui parle de l'islam et
c est ce que vous pensez qu est-ce qui
s'est trompé sur ces sur son thème de
campagne est ce que finalement il décide
de parler de pouvoir d'achat pour aller
chercher d'autres électeurs qu est ce
que vous pensez de sa mort le sas et je
pense que je vais aimer dieu qui disent
qu'ils parlent que d'eux que des
islamistes et autres il parle également
d'économies mais les deux cents lits et
je pense les deux son billet sur le
discours d'aujourd'hui est ce que vous
attendiez certaines choses en
particulier oui tout à fait
personnellement je suis entrepreneur et
nous sommes acculés de charges sociales
et ça devient très lourd et voilà enfin
moi j'ai du mal à trouver du personnel
chez bull seul employé des traits toutes
des étrangers parce que j'arrive pas dû
parsemer français sachant qu'il ya 7
millions de chômeurs c'est inadmissible
donc baissons nos charges besson les
charges des salariés augmentant les
salaires des salariés avant de pouvoir
augmenter pouvoir d'achat tout
simplement c'est simple mais
y'a pas un roman qu'il le pense vous
qu'il le dit et je pense qu'eric zemmour
le dit clairement
voilà pour ce pour ce témoignage d'un
militant pro eric zemmour vincent est
juste une petite information on parlait
de la salle qui n'est pas tout à fait
rempli c'est le cas mais en tout cas à
la tribune on vient d'annoncer que 2000
personnes attendaient encore à
l'extérieur pour pénétrer dans le grand
palais de lille c'est en tout cas ce que
les officiels nous disent donc voilà
non666 et 2000 personnes entre la salle
devrait continuer à se remplir on attend
de voir et on vous tient au courant bien
entendu alors vous ne tenez au courant
timothée vous gardez votre votre
interlocuteur à côté de vous parce que
moi j'ai une question à lui poser vous
allez lui poser il habite dans la
banlieue de reims est-ce que pourquoi
après t-il préféré venir en meeting de
lille alors qu'il y avait le meeting de
marine le pen à reims
alors on a une autre question pour vous
messieurs
alors vous habitez donc près de reims il
se trouve que marine le pen fait
justement un meeting à reims aujourd'hui
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez privilégié
pour décider de venir à ce meeting
d'eric zemmour à lille plutôt que
d'aller à celui de marine le pen à reims
donc pour moi j'ai décidé de venir ici
parce que
le discours de marine le pen et n'est
plus audible elle et je pense que c'est
trop les rejets dans son électorat et
et voulons aller les sorties de ses
bases elle est sortie c'est penser que
parce qu'elle fait quand même des
propositions concrètes sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur la ruralité tout à mémé pop
autant que vos temps qu'eric zemmour et
postic hier voici père mais qu'est ce
que vous pensez des récent ralliement du
rassemblement national vers eric zemmour
vous pensez que c'est justement des gens
qui pensent comme vous qui pensent que
marine le pen ne va pas suffisamment
loin dans ses propositions sinon je
l'aurais pas fait il n'aurait pas aux
gens mais il n'aurait pas rejoint eric
zemmour et d'autres viendront également
moi je suis un ancien élu de rn au
niveau local et voilages et j'avais
encore moi même ma carte d'adhérent
jusqu'en 2021 j'ai rejoint
reconquête en descendent d'abord un
petit élu le maire merci beaucoup bon à
vincent pour ceux pour les réponses
merci beaucoup pour ces réponses qui
sont intéressantes on va les commenter
justement avec guillaume bernard on
continue de suivre avec vous l'événement
on continue de suivre bien entendu vous
nous dites si les la salle se remplit et
également qu'elle est le cas les le
programme peut-être parce que juste une
question thimoté j'ai l'impression que
avoir le programme d'un meeting d'eric
zemmour c'est l'un des secrets les mieux
gardés de la république
je vous le confirme vincent j'ai bien
essayé d'avoir le programme est bien des
personnes qui allaient intervenir à la
tribune avant et zemmour impossible pour
l'instant d'avoir un nom je me suis
renseigné auprès de michel bédard
ça laisse presse pour l'instant les noms
n'ont absolument pas futé c'était un
petit peu la même chose d'ailleurs pour
vivre quand il avait fallu attendre
avant que ce ne soit communiqué donc
pour l'instant on ne sait pas qui va
parler à la tribune et là les militants
sont en train et bien vous voyez sur ces
images si maxime peut-être on vous de
montrer les militants sont debout sur
leurs chaises
clamés l'arrivée de guillaume pepy à
l'afp
perez un transfuge des républicains vers
eric zemmour qui est donc en train de
rentrer dans l'édifice peut-être va-t-il
prend la parole en tout cas son arrivée
vers le devant de la scène semble
imminente et bien si guillaume pelletier
prend la parole on l'écoutera justement
peut-être guillaume un commentaire sur
sa pendant juste avant je salue les
internautes qui nous ont rejoints sur le
chat du figaro cette fois ci et en
particulier messi qui me saluent
rebonjour messi ricard également brahim
dingue également qu'ils sont nous ont
rejoints et vous êtes nombreux à
commenter ça y est le débat a commencé
on le sent sur le chat et vous êtes là
le chat il est là également pour
favoriser le débat qui est l'un des adn
du figaro on voit effectivement on pense
dans l'allée
responsable de la campagne d'eric
zemmour lance trochut la trempe du
mouvement conservateur philippe de
villiers qui salue gilbert collard
première apparition donc de gilbert
collard au côté d'eric zemmour la
première une des premières apparitions
ce qui est déjà apparu à câble à cannes
nouvelle donc apparition au temps pour
moi de guillaume de gilbert collard
le fait que d'ailleurs on parle donc
d'une l'arrivée de guillaume pelletier
peut-être qu'il va prendre la parole
dans un instant
est-ce que ça n'illustre pas ce que
disait guillaume tabard dans le fig dans
le figaro aujourd'hui que la véritable
le véritable objectif aujourd'hui pour
eric zemmour c'est peut-être pas marine
le pen mais c'est valérie pécresse
en tout cas c'est une nécessité je sais
pas si c'est son objectif parce que
je crois qu'ils essayent évidemment
comme n'importe quel candidat d'élargir
le plus de la manière la plus grande
possible son électorat c'est une absolue
nécessité parce que d'abord
s'il veut pouvoir effectivement dire
qu'il réalise une union des droites ce
qui me paraît difficile ou plutôt une
unité de la droite ce qui me paraît plus
cohérent et d'autre part s'il veut
effectivement essayé d'atteindre le
deuxième tour il est certain que étant
donné que le socle électoral populaire
de marine le pen semble ferme il ne peut
effectivement espérer progresser que
sylla et bien que s'ils enquête sur le
le l'espace politique de valérie
pécresse
je dirais que
c'est directement lié à ce que vous
évoquez avec timothée tout à l'heure le
fait qu'on ne connaisse pas la liste des
intervenants dans les meetings je crois
tout simplement que il ne la communique
pas parce qu'ils espèrent chaque jour
essayer d'engranger un certain nombre de
ralliement on sait tous qu'il ya des
tractations par derrière et que il
espère pouvoir les activer de telle
manière qu'il puisse continuer à faire
le storytelling le storytelling pardon
le storytelling décidément je vais avoir
du mal pour dire que voilà au fur et à
mesure du temps qui passe il ya de plus
en plus de rallier à eric zemmour et
donc voilà je crois qu'ils espéraient je
crois qu'on peut dire qu'ils espéraient
pour ce meeting de lille pouvoir annoncé
le ralliement d'un certain nombre de
personnalités tout naturellement je ne
donnerai évidemment pas les non moi je
ne fais pas du coming out forcé
apparemment
en tout cas vu ce que nous en savons
pour l'instant ces personnes n'ont pas
encore décidé de d'afficher l'heure
l'heure le ralliement donc à eric
zemmour mais il est absolument certain
que si eric zemmour veut réussir la
recomposition politique s'il ne se
cantonne qu'à essayer de se substituer à
marine le pen ou à affaiblir marine le
pen pour l'empêcher au final d'être au
deuxième tour avec lui le fait qu'il ne
puisse lui même ne pas y être il est
certain qu'il aura raté cette
recomposition politique alors on va y
revenir on va peut-être
retourner à lille voir un petit peu
quelle est l'ambiance avant le début du
meeting et répondre à
certains certains internautes qui
commentent qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux à commenter réagir sur le site
du figaro
alors me dis que les places de devant
sont maintenant remplies et
effectivement les places de devancer
souvent celle sont réservés aux
officiels ce qui est ce qui était
derrière effectivement on voit lio mme
pelletier et philippe de villiers donc
pour l'instant pas de grand ralliement
que l'on voit et
le débat donc continue beaucoup de
commentaires autour de ce militant qu'on
vient d'entendre ce qui vous a frappé
dans ce que vous avez entendu chez ce
militant de la banlieue de reims moi ce
qui m'a particulièrement marqué c'est le
fait qu' il a avoué qu'à la fin qu'il
était un ancien militant de du
rassemblement national et qu' il en
était déçu et que c'était cette raison
que c'était pour cette raison qu'il
avait rejoint eric zemmour vous noterez
que c'est un ancien est lui même un élu
local sans doute conseiller municipal et
que donc par conséquent il n'avait pas
de hautes responsabilités
n'étant pas dans l'exécutif je dirais
d'une d'une collectivité territoriale
mais il n'empêche que voilà marine le
pen a vraisemblablement créer les
conditions où elle a contribué à créer
les conditions pour l'émergence d'eric
zemmour lc du point de vue électoral et
sociologique désintéresser des électeurs
conservateurs et de l'autre côté elle a
pratiqué à l'intérieur de son parti
politique une direction pour dire
qu'elle est assez autoritaire et donc
par conséquent va évidemment elle a
contribué à l'appel d'air qui a favorisé
l'émergence d'eric zemmour mais pour
autant ça ne veut pas dire qu'il va y
avoir une hémorragie de tout l'électorat
de marine le pen vers eric zemmour est
enfin là ce qu'on a vu c'était quand
même un ancien un ancien élu et un
original hector et on est parfaitement
d'accord il y a aujourd'hui 4 3 4 5 % de
l'électorat marine le pen qui il y a 6
mois encore comptait voter pour elle
pour le premier tour et qui a fait que
il désormais ils votent pour eric
zemmour où ils ont l'intention de voter
pour eric zemmour et donc elle est
passée de 22 à 17 18 % ça n'empêche que
il reste un socle de 17 à 18% des
lecteurs et avec ce socle là elle est
devant et valérie pécresse est largement
devant 20 assez largement devant eric
zemmour donc il est certain que
il y à une hémorragie d'une partie de
l'électorat et des cadres du
rassemblement national vers eric zemmour
enfin je voudrais vous rappeler un
événement historique
1999 scission au sein du front national
bruno mégret quitte avec les deux tiers
des élus et des cadres le front national
en 2002 bruno mégret fait 2 % la
présidentielle et jean marie le pen
c'est présent au second tour on n'oublie
pas quand même que aux européennes de
99,5 bruno mégret fait à peu près le
même score qui fera à la présidentielle
et le jean marie le pen ne fait que 5 à
10% on va retourner à lille voit un
petit peu quelle est l'ambiance
au à lille grand palais alors qu'il ya
encore des nouveaux messages qui
arrivent sur les tchats je vous donne la
parole dans un instant les images
d'abord
alors timothée timothée d'hellemmes nous
entend apparemment
apparemment le meeting est sur le point
de commencer thimoté
oui tout à fait vincent là l'ambiance je
vous disais tout à l'heure que la bourse
était quand même assez calme là
l'ambiance est clairement monté d'un
cran des grosses musique de campagne
d'une tête diffusé hélas le meeting qui
commença à débuter avec la première
intervention à la tribune les militants
qui sont en train est bien de s'asseoir
pour cette toute première intervention
et nous sommes en train d'apercevoir
jean frédéric poisson qui est le premier
en permettant au président de l'ancien
parti
démocrate parti des chrétiens démocrates
pardon et chris haney qui s'appelle
maintenant la via de la voix du peuple
voilà jean frédéric poisson qui commence
donc son son intervention
piques acerbes
mais bon
martine aubry la maire socialiste de
lille
viens manifester contre l'extrême droite
dans la ville voilà le début de
l'intervention de jean frédéric poisson
et puis simplement ressent sur le
remplissage voilà donc là vous le voyez
sur ces images la salle est quand même
bien remplie ce que je vous disais tout
à l'heure c'est que il y avait tout un
tout un quart de la salle sur au fond au
fond à droite qui n'étaient pas remplies
maxime est en train de vous montrer
maxime le riz est en train de vous
montrer les chaises se sont
considérablement considérablement pardon
rempli de climat précédentes
interventions mais malgré tout vous le
voyez à sion ces images certaines
chaises sont encore vides voilà mais on
est quand même boulot tiers ou chaise
vide que dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure la salle s'est entre temps assez
assez rempli quand même merci timothée
pour ces précisions on va les écouter
jean frédéric poisson et on revient vers
vous et également vers guillaume bernard
qui nous fera le commentaire juste après
[Musique]
nous sommes le premier pays du monde en
termes de pression fiscale
le premier en termes de dépenses
publiques nous avons deux quatrièmes de
chômage de plus élevés d'europe le
onzième temps d'espérance de vie pour la
mortalité prénatal le 12e pays de
l'union européenne ne sommes en nombre
de millions de morts de mort du comique
partant par million d'habitants nous
sommes le 21e pays du monde en ce qui
concerne restes de repas dansant certes
espérance de vie
le 26e pays de l' ocde en ce qui
concerne la qualité de notre éducation
le 37e en ce qui concerne l'efficacité
de la justice et tout ça mais cheikh
hamid à la grande gloire de notre
ministre des finances nous a coûté 500
milliards d'euros de dette
supplémentaire on peut pas dire vous
êtes une bonne affaire
le bilan de mes news macron en plus
c'est en d2 mon record c'est la violence
qui s'installe partout des corps
intermédiaires qui sont laminés lissa
points terrain d'immigration qui
s'installe sera que personne ne leur
résiste le rabotage incessants les
libertés publiques et individuelles et
je veux ici spécialement
remercier lyrique zemmour d'avoir pris
l'engagement d'être le seul candidat à
avoir promis qu'il approcherait sans
délai tous les textes qui réduisent au
brésil vient de liberté tous les pass de
toutes sortes merci à lui
[Applaudissements]
emmanuel macron c'est le mépris
permanent du peuple c'est l'arrogance
augmente comme mode de gouvernement
c'est la maltraitance des travailleurs
salariés c'est la maltraitance des
enfants qui sont empêchés d'être éduquer
correctement parce qu'ils forcent hamas
cas d'école toute la journée
c'est
la maltraitance des personnes âgées dans
nos maisons de retraite qu'on a laissé
mourir depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire
colas quel est le bilan de manière à
combler il ya plus grave des animaux en
plus de la nécessité pour tous de sortir
de ce bilan terrible et de sa
prolongation
emmanuel macron prépare avec l'union
européenne
l'identité numérique la suppression
la suppression de l'argent liquide
la mise sous contrôle des politiques
migratoires européennes avec le pack
migratoire européen et au fond ce qui
nous attend c'est le contrôle social à
la chinoise du guéry g par le règne de
l'argent au mépris de nos intérêts de
nos libertés et de notre dignité voilà
ce qui nous attend si emmanuel la crau
où l'un de ses clones est réélu
alors mes amis
puisque nous avons beaucoup de temps à
passer ensemble mais que je dois
terminer rapidement
pourquoi faut-il soutenir eric zemmour
parce que d'abord c'est le seul qui se
soit engagé aaron de manière définitive
avec toutes ses politiques avec la
soumission de la france c'est le seul
qui veut rendre à notre pays à nous tous
les libertés que nous avons conquise
dans l'histoire grâce aux générations
qui nous ont précédés le seul je veux
refaire de la france un pays libre et
indépendant
le seul qui veut faire cesser la
fabrication de la pauvreté et de
l'indignité qui est la gangrène de la
société française le seul qui veut
rendre aux entrepreneurs aux familles
aux territoires aux associations les
libertés qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû
perdre le seul à avoir un projet qui
respecte à la fois notre histoire notre
peuple voilà pourquoi il faut le
soutenir et voilà comme vous tout comme
vous pourquoi je suis là aujourd'hui en
étant certain que nous gagnerons cette
élection présidentielle merci de votre
courage de votre engagement vivre avec
la douleur
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'en ferai des poissons on va
retrouver dans un instant timothée
d'hellemmes un court commentaire peut
être
une guillaume sur ce qu'on vient de ce
qu'on vient d'entendre donc jean
frédéric poisson qui était longtemps
proche de christine boutin a vendu avant
de lui succéder qui avait été l'un des
tout premiers alliés et règlements
c'est effectivement quelqu'un qui a été
peut être un peu éclipsé par d'autres
ralliements alors que depuis le début il
a été un de ceux qui a contribué à
l'émergence de à l'émergence zemmour je
note que dans ce discours là on va voir
au long de la journée quelles vont être
les cibles
la cible c'est emmanuel macron et il a
insisté sur deux points qui me
paraissent très caractéristique je
dirais de la tendance catholique sociale
qui est qu incarne jean frédéric poisson
la défense des libertés publiques thème
sur lequel il faut bien le dire eric
zemmour a quand même été un peu timorés
un considérant que ça le détournerait de
son objectif principal qui est de parler
de l'islamisation donc il a été plus
timorés que d'autres candidats
et puis deuxième thème la question du
social ou là il est certain que la fibre
catholique de jean frédéric poisson la
défense des personnes handicapées des
personnes vulnérables
effectivement a été mise en exergue dans
son dans son discours c'est aussi une
manière aussi de revenir en creux sur la
polémique qui a eu suite aux
déclarations d'eric zemmour sur les
enfants handicapés pourri qui était pour
le moins maladroite même si on peut
effectivement comprendre je dirais ça
logique mais vous veillez parfois quand
on est trop certains d'un prisme
interprétatif et bien
en l'occurrence la question des
discriminations etc
l'on n'est pas forcément toujours très
pas forcément toujours très claires ont
très bien compris là dans cette affaire
des personnes handicapées il s'est
rattrapé mais c'est vrai que la première
version de son de sa prise de position
eric zemmour était été assez maladroite
et difficilement compréhensible ok on va
retourner je dis ok puisqu'on me dis que
timothée d'hellemmes et avec un ancien
transfuge du front national du
rassemblement national enfin il y avait
quitté le rassemblement national m
depuis quelques temps c'est jean messia
[Musique]
oui vincent avec jean mais s'il ya porte
parole de reconquête bonjour merci de
nous accorder cette interview
ce meeting d'eric zemmour à lille dans
les hauts de france c'est tout un
symbole qu'est ce qu'il faut attendre de
cette prise de parole bah écoutez vous
savez que eric zemmour fait des meetings
qui sont des meetings thématiques on a
déjà parlé de l'école de la ruralité
aujourd'hui ce meeting est consacrée au
pouvoir d'achat et je pense que dans la
région nord effectivement qu est une
région aussi à ces sinistrés
industriellement où les gens ont aussi
beaucoup de mal à boucler leurs fins de
mois le discours sur le pouvoir d'achat
avec des mesures très concrètes
évidemment va être très était très
attendu ici comme je le rappelle eric
zemmour parle beaucoup d'identité il a à
juste titre décidé d'en faire
comment dirais-je le point cardinal de
sa campagne présidentielle et sa
thématique présidentielle mais il y a
aussi le mode le comment dirais-je le
pouvoir d'achat toutes les mesures
permettant
d'accroître le niveau de vie des
français qui a été particulièrement
malmenées ces dernières années donc le
discours d'aujourd'hui est un discours
très pragmatique très portait
effectivement sur les mesures qui vont
être entreprises pour augmenter le
salaire net et augmenter le salaire n'a
le pouvoir d'achat des français eric
zemmour a dit et répété qu'il souhaitait
faire de l'identité de l'immigration de
l'islam et bien vraiment le plus piliers
de sa campagne aujourd'hui ce grand
meeting est consacrée uniquement au
pouvoir d'achat est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il s'est trompé de qui s'est trompé
thème non pas du tout vous savez dans
une dans une campagne présidentielle
c'est un peu comme dans une tendance
dans un édifice il ya la pierre
angulaire mais il ya aussi toutes les
autres pierres alors c'est vrai que la
pierre angulaire de la delà du discours
d'eric zemmour est identitaire elle et
elle est axée sur l'identité
l'immigration la sécurité ça c'est un
fait mais c'est pas une thématique
exclusive c'est à dire que quand vous
êtes candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il vous faut
naturellement avoir un programme un
projet présidentiel qui couvre tous les
domaines que sont ceux du daim que j'ai
un président de la république donc il ya
un programme européen un programme
économique un programme agricole un
programme éducatif au même titre que les
autres mais effectivement on décide en
fonction chacun en fonction de ses
convictions et bien d'accès la campagne
présidentielle sur une thématique
particulière et eric zemmour axe cette
thématique particulière sur l'identité
marine le pen a accordé hier une longue
interview au figaro dans laquelle elle a
un petit peu taclé l'électorat de
reese est en tout cas elle a dit qu'on
trouvait chez chez eric zemmour est bien
des catholiques traditionalistes
d'anciens nazis je crois voilà qu'est ce
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
déclarations de marine le pen que vous
connaissez bien bah écoutez je pense
qu'elle est un peu en état de panique et
qu'elle est en état de choc parce que
c'est pas ce sont des déclarations qui
sont pas du tout raisonnable et jamais
des catholiques traditionalistes
avec des nazis ça paraît quand même
assez douteux en plus elle elle avoue
que c'est les soi-disant nazis qu'elle
dénonce chez nous et était chez elle au
préalable chose qu'elle n'avait jamais
reconnu pendant les 40 dernières années
où précisément tout le système
médiatico-politique l'accuser de les
avoir donc ça paraît quand même assez
incroyable comme comme aveu indirects et
puis l'idée qui consiste à dire que les
nazis les soi-disant nazis auraient
quitté un parti dirigé par des blonds
aux yeux bleus pour rejoindre un juif je
vous laisse apprécier le mauvais goût de
la comparaison sur les ralliements à
eric zemmour il ya quand même beaucoup
de membres du rassemblement national
enfin quelques-uns en tout cas qu'ils
sont en train petit à petit de rallier
eric zemmour est ce que vous pensez que
qu'il ya une véritable hémorragie que ça
va continuer ou pas est ce que vous
appelez peut-être d'autres élus à vous
rejoindre bah écoutez moi j'appelle tous
les militants tous les adhérents tous
les élus du rassemblement national à
nous rejoindre parce que la candidature
vient exhiber la seule gagnante
le problème c'est que le rassemblement
national a évidemment tenu cette
problématique pendant des cadets pendant
40 ans grâce d'ailleurs lui en soit
rendue aux militants et à ses adhérents
mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
l'incarnation des idées portées par le
rassemblement national depuis tant
d'années elle c'est eric zemmour
davantage que marine le pen voilà c'est
un fait un dernier mot jean messia sur
le climat de cette campagne à un climat
qui est parfois un petit peu délétère on
a vu quelques quelques piques quand même
que ce soit avec marine le pen avec
d'autres est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est un climat suffisamment serein on
parle de la stature présidentielle eric
zemmour at il fait ses preuves à votre
avis à ce niveau là bas vous savez quand
vous connaissez un petit peu l'histoire
politique
des élections présidentielles sous la
vème république le premier tour à la n'a
jamais vraiment été une promenade de
santé le premier tour est un est un est
une sorte de primaire en réalité où tous
les candidats s'affrontent parfois
brutalement virilement mais c'est aussi
le poumon de la démocratie qu de se
critiquer et de se dire les choses en
face je veux dire
la france a besoin de ces clivages qui
sont forts dans une atmosphère que
d'aucuns voudraient de plus en plus
aseptisée feutrée capitonné le fait le
frottement des idées lorsqu'il s'exprime
de manière intelligente mais même
véhémente est souhaitable et c'est le
signe d'une respiration démocratique qui
je crois est attendu par les français
vous pensez qu'un débat par exemple eric
zemmour marine le pen avant le havre
pour mes tours un peu comme celui qu'on
a vu avec jean mélange jean luc
mélenchon serait une bonne chose mais
vous savez en fait la démocratie il
n'est de démocratie que de débats
les débats c'est la démocratie au
concret on peut pas parler de démocratie
comme si c'était un objet volant non
identifié la démocratie prend racine
dans la discussion dans le débat dans
l'expression des désaccords c'est ça la
démocratie donc les gens qui ne veulent
pas débattre ne sont réels étaient pas
des démocrates
non je ne sais pas écouter vous appeler
aujourd'hui marine le pen à débattre
avec eric zemmour j'appelle tous les
dons de lait perdent toutes les
personnes
candidate à l'élection présidentielle à
avoir le courage de débattre que ce soit
emmanuel macron et ne doit pas se croit
protégé par son statut de président de
la république parce que il est président
de la république certes mais s'il
devient candidat il doit descendre dans
l'arène et il doit débattre comme
n'importe quel candidat c'est donc c'est
ce que je dis pour rien mais emmanuel
macron est aussi valable pour marine le
pen pour jean luc mélenchon pour un
zemmour pour tous les candidats à la
présidentielle le débat est salutaire ça
fait partie de la tradition républicaine
des débats démocratiques avant les
progrès réalisés les sons présidentielle
merci beaucoup gens mais si un porte
parole de reconquête alors que les
discours sont en train est bien de
continuer à se succéder à la tribune
merci beaucoup timothée quand vous
reverrez jean messia ou bien quand vous
reverrez un des responsables de la
campagne d'eric zemmour il ya une
question qui est posée dans le chat et
on aimerait bien avoir la réponse est ce
que eric zemmour à ses 500 signatures
est-ce que combien dispose-t-il
aujourd'hui de deux signatures je vous
laisse partir à la pêche aux infos
pendant ce temps leur effectivement on a
vu jacqueline gourault prendre la parole
jacqueline moreau c'est une figure des
gilet jaune et on va on va l'écouter
juste avant peut-être un petit un petit
commentaire sur deux points d'abord ce
qu'on vient d'entendre
guillaume commentaires courts et
commentaires courts également sur un
autre
fait qui se produisait au même moment
c'était la prise de parole de bruno
north bruno north c'est le responsable
d'un parti un petit parti qui est le cni
est ce que vous pouvez justement nous
nous éclairer sur sur ça est-ce que ça
comme signification oui alors il ya
beaucoup d'éléments sur ce qu'a dit jean
messia mais peut-être qu'on pourrait y
glaner çà on commence par bruno barde
bruno north alors le sel ni paix c'est
un vieux parti c'est un des plus vieux
parti c'est pas le plus vieux parti en
france que c'est le parti radical et le
plus ancien mais c'est un des plus vieux
parti
jean marie le pen en a été un élu donc
comme valéry giscard d'estaing comme
valéry giscard d'estaing c'est une c'est
ce qu'on appelle un comment dire un
parti charnière c'est à dire que c'est
les organisations qui permettent de
faire
comment dire des d'évoluer dans le
spectre politique de manière je dirais
lente sans que sans que l'on soit je
dirais sans que l'on passe d'une
organisation à une autre c'était un
mariage trop je vous pose a besoin trop
flagrante ce que on entendait toujours
c'est que c'est un parti conservateur
oui absolument we say say say say très
clair c'est un des c'est un tout petit
parti un joli rica il ya que quelques
élus qui
on c'est éthique est là mais il y en a
d'abord quelques-uns et puis dans
l'histoire de la droite mine de rien
c'est une organisation qui représente
quelque chose aujourd'hui ça ne
représente en termes de voix pas grand
monde mais ça représente quelque chose
en terme de en terme de symbole alors
justement je voudrais parmi les choses
qui seraient a commenté me parler de la
question des transfuges ou des ralliés
je crois que
il est très clair que hormis une
personnalité énormément d'envergure les
transfuges je dirais n'entraîne pas de
transferts de voix il très peu en
revanche il est évident que lorsqu'une
personnalité qui est un parti pour en
rejoindre un autre ça sème la zizanie
dans l'organisation qu'il quitte donc
c'est beaucoup plus ça tu dirais qu'il
est dommageable à marine le pen lorsque
des cadres ou des élus le kit la quittes
que le fait qu'ils vont entraîner
énormément de voix derrière eux et si
vous me permettez ce commentaire sur la
sphère néo nazi qu'il y aurait j'ai le
temps j'ai une minute ou une minute mais
alors sur la sphère des lasi donc la
crasse zeman est exact de faire la
citation exacte de marine le pen c'est à
dire qu'il ya des caves des catholiques
traditionalistes des communautaristes et
dit-elle quelqu'une quelques nazis je
crois que contrairement à ce qu'a dit
jean messia ça n'est pas une fébrilité
de sa part c'est une stratégie dans le
sens où elle sait qu il y as au sein de
reconquête des réorganisations il ya
plusieurs strates qui se sont formés
très rapidement ce qui était dans les
ami d'eric zemmour qui étaient des
militants depuis un certain temps qui
lui ont permis d'ailleurs d'envisager
ensuite d'aller à la présidentielle or
il y à là la structuration d'un parti
politique ce qui entraîne le fait que
certaines personnes soient démis de
leurs fonctions et remplacés par
d'autres et je crois qu'elle veut
attisées je dirais les les rancoeurs au
sein de reconquête en sortant ce genre
de phrase là beaucoup plus que le fait
qu'elle puisse croire qu'il y ait
d'autres antique nazis auprès d'eric
zemmour je crois que là elles vivent
disons la frange païenne identitaire qui
a rejoint eric zemmour avait lieu
quelques dès aujourd'hui commence à être
un peu évincés des responsabilités au
sein de reconquête on y reviendra
peut-être parce que il y avait également
des réminiscences d'un autre phénomène
dont vous aviez parlé qui était la
scission du front national en 1999 et il
me semble qu'il y avait dans ses
rhétorique dans ses accusations quelque
chose qui relève entre les cas de cette
époque bien sûr on va écouter jacques
limouzy l'une des figures du mouvement
des gilet jaune est en train de
s'adresser aux militants réunis où
on pas les grands lits à lille grand
palais paraît pardon excusez mon écoute
site existe-t-il plus noble cause
commune dans cette campagne que d'avoir
l'ambition que sauver la france
lui évite ses goûts et votre présente
hâtif de la culture populaire souhaité
par tant de français oui eric zemmour
s'est déjà rassemblé la multitude autour
d'une grande aspiration de reconquête et
de partage oui nous voulons recueillir
le plus grand nombre de suffrages oui
nous voulons une adhésion à nos idées à
notre action oui nous voulons lutter
contre toutes les défaitisme c'est
pourquoi ne nous focalisons pas sur les
sondages qui on est systématiquement de
préciser qu'il ya entre 35 et 50% des
électeurs qui ne savent même pas s'ils
iront voter ni pour qui
ainsi il appartient à chacun de nous de
rassembler chaque jour un peu plus
toutes les forces françaises libres
fédérant notre enthousiasme et notre
courage pour suivre le meilleur
rassembleur caire eric zemmour
il est en train de réussir là où tous
les autres ont échoué
réunir les français pour défendre la
france protéger les vies de chacun pour
tous les âges et toutes les formes de
dépendance celle du premier âge comme
celle du grand âge eric zemmour nous
garantit plus qu'un avenir il nous offre
un destin
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc jacqueline moreau figure donc
du mouvement
gilet jaune
peut-être un commentaire d'ailleurs sûr
on l'avait déjà fait avec arnaud
benedetti lors du meeting de villepinte
jacqueline moreau est ce que c'est
également une réponse à cette à ceux qui
critiquent en tous les cas à cette
dimension
peut-être mais quand on va y revenir
d'eric zemmour celle qui concerne le
pouvoir d'achat
je crois qu évidemment le fait qu'il lui
donne la parole hormis peut-être
l'amitié où l'intérêt qu'il a pour
comment dire pour elle c'est évidemment
le fait d'essayer de capter une partie
de l'électorat populaire jusqu'à présent
ça n'est pas toujours très efficace je
vous rappelle notamment que les gilet
jaune n'avait pas de porte parole que
c'était dans le fond un mouvement né
quasiment ex nihilo de la base et qui
c'était comment dire qu'ils avaient
éclos un peu partout en france donc il
est évident qu'il ya un certain nombre
de gilet jaune qui seront sans doute
satisfait et séduit par le fait que l'un
d'entre eux ou l'une d'entre eux est
bien a rejoint eric zemmour et sa vallée
poussera peut-être effectivement à faire
de même mais ça ne veut pas dire que
l'ensemble du mouvement des gilet jaune
soit derrière soit derrière eric zemmour
est le fait de donner la parole à un
gilet jaune qui a une visibilité
médiatique même relative mais tout de
même réel c'est évidemment dans le but
d'essayer de d'attirer à à la corde à
tirer pour eric zemmour des voix
populaires il faudra analyser la part du
voide gilet jaune dans le vote est mort
le soir du premier tour oui si on arrive
effectivement si les instituts de
sondage ont des critères de
d'identification suffisamment claire oui
ce sera évidemment important parce que
ils ont été un mouvement extrêmement
important du point de vue de l'histoire
sociale parce qu'ils sont nés hors parti
et hors syndicat donc ça c'est
extrêmement important mais pour autant
la traduction politique d gilet jaune
jusqu'à présent c'est quasiment rien
parce que aux européennes ce qui avait
tenté de lancer des listes n'ont pas
réussi quoique ce soit et ensuite il y a
eu de très forte abstention aux
élections municipales départementales et
régionales donc pour l'instant la
traduction politique d gilet jaune et
bah ça n'est pas encore arrivé peut-être
que ça viendra avec la présidentielle
mais
pour l'instant on est aux alentours de
35 % d'abstention ça baissera sans doute
et 35 % d'abstention pour une
présidentielle s'il devait arriver ça
serait beaucoup
on va y revenir pardon est en train de
me parler dans l'oreille donc
effectivement comme je suis un homme
assez séquentiel le fait que deux je
fais pas plusieurs choses à la fois
pardonnez-moi bien on nous demande de
laisser écouter les orateurs c'est ce
qu'on va faire
parce que d'après elle nous représentons
le racisme et l'extrême droite
il n'y a ici
ni raciste ni gens d'extrême droite il y
à des français qui aiment la france
martin
et elle a osé dire
lamartine au martinez islamo gauchiste
elle a osé dire que tout cela c'est
étonnant de la république fraternelle
mais ces poids
sa république fraternelle
c'est celle qui fait traiter eric
zemmour de chiens
c'est celle
c'est une scène qui fait dire sale juif
c'est celle qui fait dire nique ta mère
alors que ma mère c'est la france
ça ce n'est pas la république
fraternelle c'est la république de la
haine de la haine des autres
de la haine de la france et ce qui fait
qu'on nous
brocarde qu on nous insulte
c'est que nous représentons quelque
chose qui devient extraordinaire
c'est la vibration qui remonte au vol de
l'alouette de cet amour de la france ils
ne le comprennent pas ils ne le
ressentent pas il ne le devine pas et
ils ont rencontré un homme qui est porté
par cet amour comme par une force qui
s'enracine dans toute l'histoire dans
toute la langue dans toute la poésie
dans toute la géographie ils ne le
comprennent pas ces petits technocrates
qui ont écrit les discours et qui les
annoncent parfois sans comprendre ils ne
savent pas qu'il ya un amour de la
france qui peut être plus fort que tout
sa république fraternelle
ce n'est pas à roubaix
ce n'est pas le père hamel égorgé sa
république fraternelle ce n'est pas le
professeur pâtit sa république
fraternelle ce n'est pas
nice le massacre ce pauvre monsieur
jardin qui pleure et qu'on méprise la
république fraternelle elle est ici
parce que nous on s'aime à travers
l'amour de la france et personne n'y
peut rien
tout à l'heure
j'ai presque fini c'est mon compteur est
épuisé tout à l'heure vous entendrez je
pense jacques clostermann
il va vous porter un témoignage et il va
vous parler de son père mais sachez que
sur les 287 pilotes des forces aériennes
françaises dont son père faisait partie
héros de la bataille d'angleterre il y a
eu 69 survivants c'était ça la france du
ciel des combats qui ne cédait devant
rien
et je remercie mon ami
et mes amis ici présent
et je remercie tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent
parce que il y à l'économie mais il ya
aussi la force de l'esprit il y a le
pouvoir d'achat et il ya le pouvoir dès
mai et rien ne se fait sans la force de
l'esprit et merci d'avoir évoqué la
chute de notre dame parce
qu'effectivement au moment où on a vu
les ailes de pierres tombées dans le
ciel on a eu mal et quand on a vu la
flèche s'abattre elle est allée dans
notre coeur et on a eu mal et on a
souffert et bien cette souffrance cette
douleur de ce que la france devient en
vain qu'il se transforme en un
ensoleillement de la victoire et c'est
avec eric zemmour c'est avec vous qu'on
y arrivera vive l'amour de la france
vive la montre la république
alors gilbert collard donc été l'une des
la dea récent ralliement et qu on avait
déjà entendu à cannes
pour ceux qui avaient suivi le meeting à
ce moment-là
peut-être un rapide un rapide
commentaire
effectivement il a donné la pleine
mesure de ses compétences en tout cas en
matière oratoire cac et gilbert collard
qui est pas mal plaidé évidemment dans
les juridictions pénales tribunaux
correctionnels et courez cour d'assises
évidemment à la fée des effets de manche
c'est la règle du jeu bien entendu de
n'importe quel meeting quelle que soit
la couleur politique quel que soit le
quel que soit le candidat
symboliquement c'est quand même
important ce ralliement parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui avait contribué en fait à
la stratégie de dédiabolisation de
marine le pen rappelez vous il avait
créé ce qu'il avait appelé le
rassemblement bleu marine il avait bien
dit qu'il n'aurait jamais rejoint le
front national s'il avait été encore
dirigé par jean-marie le pen vous dirai
en divorce de jean-marie le pen il est
aux côtés de la belle pierre épouse de
jean marie le voilà et donc il a rejoint
il a rejoint donc marine le pen il a
contribué à la stratégie de
dédiabolisation de marine le pen bon et
là d'une certaine manière il retourne un
et c'est vrai que dans un certain nombre
de ralliement à eric zemmour il ya quand
même beaucoup de gens qui font un chemin
inverse qu'ils avaient déjà fait jérôme
rivière députés européens étant de
rendre la parole avait été auparavant
députés à l'assemblée nationale ump on
va être donc jusqu'à manger a quand même
des allers retours plus que je dirais
des évolutions profondes on va écouter
justement jérôme jérôme rivière je salue
'une charles qui nous a rejoint qu'il
savait je vous salue charles merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous marcus vie qui
vient également de nous rejoindre et qui
nous demande quel est le nombre de
participants l'aria 8000 personnes qui
ont été entendues 8000 personnes qui ont
été annoncées par l'équipe zemmour tout
à l'heure on voyait que certaines
chaises étaient encore vides dès que
timothée d'hellemmes aura recharger les
batteries et sera de nouveau avec nous
en direct on lui posera la question en
écoute sur aubry
j'ai pu le dire à cannes mais je leur
dirai encore aujourd'hui ce qui fait
chaud au coeur c'est votre enthousiasme
c'est vous qui portait cette campagne
c'est vous qui venez nombreux sans bus
sans transport particulier pour soutenir
eric zemmour et c'est à vous que je veux
dire merci
la violence c'est aussi la poignée de
racaille dans tifa les authentiks
fasciste a mené par madame aubry
et à ces gens là nous leur disons que
nous continuerons que nous irons partout
pourquoi parce que partout on est chez
nous
[Applaudissements]
oui on est chez nous on est chez nous et
en votre nom à tous je dirais à eric
nous comptons sur toi mais cher eric tu
peux compter sur l'eau douce
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc jérôme rivière anciens
députés l'ump ancien proche de philippe
de villiers rallier ensuite à marine le
pen et qui est donc rallié maintenant à
eric zemmour avant de commenter ce qu'on
vient d'entendre
une précision tout à l'heure vous avez
été nombreux à nous dire mais est ce que
c'est normal qu'on ait entendu des
morceaux de hip hop pendant que parler
jacqueline moreau et bien effectivement
c'était la campagne en tous les cas le
site de campagne de d'eric zemmour qui
avait mis cette musique on essaiera de
savoir pourquoi peut-être avant de
commenter jérôme rivière var et qu'on va
écouter celle qui est en train de
prendre la parole qui est l'ancien
l'ancien eurodéputé
rassemblement national qui est la
dernière arrivée sur
chez eric
zemmour pardon max est pire bakkas
justement qui avait rallié marine le pen
elle juste avant les élections
européennes
on l'écouté et après on commente les
deux interventions
engagement politique
vos convictions sont plus forts que les
insultes et les coups tordus
non
remercier eric fait mois dont nous avons
redonné confiance et envie d'un nouveau
personnage soit pour la presse et ses
autres maires
non j'en attends tu as plus qu'un
battement et désolation l'agent
navailles à chaque jour le mouvement
national péricliter
dans sa dimension militante là où je ne
rencontrais plus que sa vie d'élu
morazin je retrouve ici un reconquête
capacité à recevoir rassembler et cette
volonté de combattre mes chers
compatriotes
et ma foi qu'on promet enfin les
possesseurs de la version 1 qu'on
appelle le peuple se lève et c'est
l'espoir pas partout refleurit toulouse
monaco plus que sept points et moi seul
qui peut le battre cette fin a soustrait
caledon leur demander de plus
j'aurais enlevé
une confidence les trois maires peu
connue en afrique n est pas seulement
moi
tu as pu savoir pour quel point toute la
matière nous avons 100 caractères
nous sommes pleins de talent and soon
ont un coût de 110 g l'année pas de
doute
eh bien ma vie je peux pas dire du tout
simplement kg ha ou de deuil pour toi
ce que j'ai apprécié quand je t'ai
rencontré pour la première fois c'est sa
simplicité sa capacité des couteaux
l'humanité et la gentillesse dans les
outre-mer nous avons assez de ces
marchands de rêves
[Applaudissements]
exposant de programmes conçus pour la
métropole mais fine art et à nos
spécificités
mais ajoute rené ans nous avons une
identité notre culture nos
particularités notre authenticité et
nous nous voulons pas les portes dans
les outre-mer
sa cage un principe
ce qui n'est pas politicien pas moins
tenu de la société civile
comme tu as compris que pour porter une
parole serveuse du font toujours partie
du club
des territoires de l'expérience l'agent
nos
2,2 comparé catholique venait
rencontrent de nombreuses difficultés
accès à l'eau nettoyante faible pouvoir
d'achat pauvreté massive
économie a confié est insuffisamment
localisme fragilité sanitaire fort taux
de chômage chez les jeunes provocant
leurs études les défis sont immenses
mais jeunesse je sais aussi que change
ou demi tonne et vivait en écoutant
respectant âprement les difficultés des
îles canaries comme tu le fais nous
ferons ce report mais les outre-mers
utilisant la france
[Applaudissements]
m
alors
alors on va répondre à élise qui nous
demandaient mais qui est cette femme eh
bien c'est ce qu'on disait max est
pierre baque à ce qu'ils étaient
eurodéputé rassemblement national
jusqu'à présent et qui vient de rallier
eric zemmour s'il s'agit de quelqu'un
qui avait rencontré marine le pen en
2019 alors qu'on voit guillaume
pelletier en train de monter sur la
scène et qui a été une militante
syndicale de la notamment de la fdsea en
guadeloupe ou clavier cela étant le
grand syndicat agricole
guillaume pelletier vice-président de
reconquête s'adresse aux militants
peut-être rapide rapide commentaire
guillaume pour l'instant c'est l'un des
rares le seul en suis-je des
républicains que l'on a vu depuis le
début de l'après midi oui c'est vrai et
donc c'est il est certain que la
quadrature du cercle pour les émaux sait
que s'il veut dire qu'il fait l'union
dès droite même si pour ma part je pense
qu'il serait plus cohérent de parler de
l'unité de mer noire eh bien il est
certain que
tout ce meeting a pour principal je
dirais images le fait de taper sur
marine le pen est d'essayer de se
substituer à elles en siphonnant c'est
cadré et ses électeurs peut-être on
verra si ça fonctionne
nicolas sarkozy avec la ligne buisson
avait réussi à le faire mais
ça n'est pas évidemment certains lorsque
jérôme rivière fait et bien scandé à la
foule on est chez nous on est là
évidemment avec un slogan du
rassemblement du rassemblement national
typique et donc par conséquent
je crois que c'est toute l'ambiguïté de
la stratégie d'eric zemmour qui dit
vouloir faire l'union des droites mais
qui en revanche mais mais qui dans le
fond parce qu'il est capable de montrer
dans le cadre de ses meetings cherche
avant tout à se substituer à marine le
pen avec cette idée mais je crois qu'il
faut plus de temps pour le développer
donc on en parlera tout à l'heure avec
cette idée que marine le pen ne peut pas
gagner tandis que lui le pourrait sa
voile il évidemment voici donc ce débat
on va y revenir et s'attend qu'à cette
idée est largement commentée est
confronté aux sondages aujourd'hui dans
l'édition papier du figaro à laquelle je
vous renvoie et que vous pouvez
retrouver sur le site on écoute
guillaume pelletier
nos filles n'auront plus peur de sortir
et de vivre parce que la forme a changé
de camp
oui mes chers amis
nous sommes ici rassemblés parce que
nous aimons la place la france ces deux
mille ans d'histoire la france c'est le
pays qui a fait la synthèse entre l'état
capétiens et l'état républicain la
france c'est le pays qui a inventé la
laïcité pour faire vivre ensemble ceux
qui croient au ciel et ceux qui n'y
croient pas la force c'est le pays entre
le drapeau blanc le bras pour houle un
soin de ville au drapeau tricolore pour
faire le drapeau de la liberté
mes chers amis
la france c'est aussi un miracle
non monsieur jean luc mélenchon la fosse
sous les paniers à valmy en
1792 oui va lui ça compte mais la france
elle est née à quelques kilomètres d'ici
dans la plaine des flandres
dans un village au nom de légende le
village de bouvines
nous sommes
nous sommes le dimanche 27 juillet 1214
le jour va se lever
et l'europe toute entière est persuadé
que l'empereur germanique va terrasser
philippe auguste mais soudain
des milliers de villageois venus de tout
le nord de la france ils viennent la
ville ils viennent d'arras ils viennent
de lille viennent se mêler aux armées du
roi c'est la victoire c'est le triomphe
en un instant le petit roi de paris
devient le roi de france il est là le
miracle frein
le petit soleil un pays qui se dresse
une là sont punis version qui vient de
naître il est là le miracle français
rien n'est plus fort qu'une idée dont
l'heure est venue oui mes chers amis
l'heure est venue de la reconquête
la reconquête des territoires perdus la
reconquête des combats perdus la
reconquête du temps perdu largo quête
pour sauver notre patrie
j'en finirai par l'ats
eric zemmour qui n'est pas un politicien
eric zemmour qui nous transmet depuis
des décennies son amour de la culture de
la littérature de la poésie et du
théâtre
comment ne pas penser en cet instant un
autre concurrent le cid de corneille
mais le temps est trop cher pour le
perdre à paroles je m'arrête au discours
et je veux que tu voles viens suis-moi
macro barre et montrer ma paroisse que
ce qu'il perd en eux il leur pose
renvoie ville éric le bour dv risque de
choléra développe vite et surtout
voilà donc on vient entendre guillaume
pelletier vice-président de reconquête
qui a rappelé en creux qu'il avait été
il avait commencé sa carrière comme
professeur d'histoire un commentaire du
professeur d'histoire du droit que vous
êtes voulez que je vous parle de la
bataille de bouvines avant je pourrais
je juge pas sûr d'être tout à fait quand
même d'accord avec guillaume pelletier
sur le fait que ce que philippe onu the
august n'était que le petit roi de paris
elle est quand même fait avant la
bataille de bouvines l'a commise des
terres de jean le roi d'angleterre et le
fameux jean samper le frère de richard
coeur de lion et il avait donc du coup
récupérer les terres plantagenêt
et les terres et les terres du roi
d'angleterre donc bon il c'est une
revanche que jean sans terre veut faire
en commun en faisant une alliance avec
l'empereur autant cadre noir ainsi qu en
fait pas le sujet n'est pas de manger
guide vous allez justement un commenté
le le discours de fin de l'allocution de
guillaume pelletier mais on va peut-être
écouté justement celui qui a été
longtemps le mentor de guillaume
pelletier philippe de villiers oui
qu'est-ce que mais qu'est-ce qu'on ait
fait rage d'être avec vous
je vais ajouter un mot à ce qu'a dit
gilbert tout à l'heure
elle nous regarde la dame des 35 heures
elle vous regarde elle est en train de
se nourrir eux quand ils se réunissent
la salle est trop petite et moi si vous
je veux réussir mais trouve les
partisans un abribus suffira
vous êtes venus pour soutenir pour
encourager pour écouter celui qui va
arriver dans quelques instants
notre candidat eric zemmour est bien
aujourd'hui
je vais faire quelque chose d'inhabituel
je mets à vous livrer des confidences
je vais vous dire
qui est l'homme derrière le candidat
nous sommes amenés depuis trente six ans
nous sommes proches je le connais bien
tout à leur vie on ne lisait c'est un
homme neuf
oui c'est un homme neuf il ne vient pas
du milieu
il n'est pas un professionnel
on a vu les parties sionnel
et l'état il n'est pas le produit il
n'est pas le produit du consumérisme
politique
qui détruit la france qui corrompt
l'esprit public depuis tant de temps et
qu'ils ont diverses dans l'islam au
schisme dans l'islam en droitisme
c'est un homme neuf
qui a fait sa mue
le penseur devient homme d'état et de
l'homme d'état les français pour
découvrir au fil de la campagne
qu'il allait dos
il à l'état parce que il aller la fleur
pour h français en lui comme on disait
jadis la première flamme courage c'est
celle du discernement il ose dire ce
qu'ils voient et voient ce qu'il voit et
ce qu'il décrit c'est un processus de
décomposition
et de colonisation de la france qui nous
aident progressait et les menus d'un
quart mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
il est tard mais c est encore temps
le courage
de la réponse
audacieuse
la hardiesse
pour faire une france qui attriste à
nouveau de puissance créatrice mais pour
qu'elle soit créatrice ils ont que la
france
repasse le plein de ses fidélités qu'on
reçoit ces petites françaises
car si on ne propose pas à nos jeunes
[Musique]
notre âme nous la grandeur ou blois
alors ne nous étonnons pas qu'ils
aillent chercher d'autres dames d'autres
là d'autres demandeurs d'autres guen
et faut donc redécouvrir une école du
mérite
qu'ils ne fassent plus grandir les
plantes d'hébétude qui promènent leur
étourdissements dans l'air du temps
faire une france créatrice celle d'eric
zemmour il faut retrouver l'esprit
français l'esprit d'entreprise les
conquêtes l'esprit de fidélité l'esprit
d'entre elles aussi sur laquelle il ya
des gens qui restent au bord de la route
la troisième fleur de courage c'est le
caractère la fermeté du caractère eric
zemmour foyer le est un homme
qui est capable demain d'être un chef
d'état
un flex et il a le mental d'un chef
chère amy je
voudrais terminer par une confidence
un jour
il ya quelques temps nous baignons tous
les deux
et je lui ai dit je te poses des
questions
qui me tient à coeur d'où vient cette
conception sacrificielle de la politique
d'où vient cet amour passionnel la
france et des français
et m'a répondu ceci
j'ai tenu la main de mon père c'était à
la fin
et mon père m'a dit mon petit eric
n'oublie jamais
n'oublie jamais de la france nous a pris
dans ses bras alors à ton tour toute ta
ville fera là d'un débat eric zemmour
eric zemmour
paye sa dette morale
il veut sauver le dépôt millénaire car
année nous sommes toutes la même france
nous sommes de la france de nos pères
qui nous ont appuyé à résister qui nous
ont appris à détester les cônes hameau
les secondes la gruyère et qu'on aborde
aujourd'hui
nous avons tous en nous la phrase
célèbre à chaque fois que la france est
approchait de la bim elle s'est
accrochée à demandes qui n'ont pas
vacillé le consens de l'épée et la
pensée française
avec
eric on t'attend il est tard mais il est
encore temps
il est temps et il n'est pas trop tard
je lui demande mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs d'accueillir le futur
président la fuite
là
et donc avant que avant que m'est arrivé
avec zemmour en scène et qu'on écoutera
peut-être un commentaire là encore on
est rapide guillaume mais sur donc ces
deux prises de parole
guillaume paul klee d'abord et puis
ensuite philippe de villiers guillaume
pelletier donc c'était ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure c'est pour l'instant
entre guillemets la caution et l'air oui
tout en sachant qu évidemment guillaume
pelletier a été d'abord au front
national puis au mpf de philippe de
villiers puis enfin à l air il n'empêche
que c'est à heller qu'il a réussi
véritablement à s'imposer d'abord
obtenir un mandat de député et puis en
2012 rappelons-nous lorsqu'il y avait eu
la guéguerre copé fillon pour la prise
du pouvoir politique il y avait une
autre élection au parallèle beaucoup
plus importante l'émotion il y avait été
votée or c'est l'émotion de la droite
forte qui était dirigée par guillaume
pelletier et geoffroy didier tu proche
de l'anglais ray pec-rhin sait
exactement qui était arrivé très
largement en tête et la droite populaire
de thierry mariani depuis a rejoint
marie le pen avait fait un très bon
score aux alentours de 12 % c'est-à-dire
qu'on avait quasiment la moitié de l air
qui avaient voté pour la droite forte et
la droite et la droite populaire donc
encore une fois les ralliements moi je
ne crois pas que cela déplace des voix
cela provoque des dysfonctionnements
dans les autres équipes quelqu'un qui en
tient lui françois bayrou qui s'était
rallié à une macro en février 2010 est
ce avec la m et c'était celui-là
potentiels à la présidentielle qui lui
même avait déjà fait un très gros score
à une élection précédente qui se rallier
c'était un désistement cd pas simplement
un ralliement c'est un serment pas je
veux citer personne pour ne vexer
personne mais dans les différentes
personnalités hormis philippe de
villiers qui a été évidemment quelqu'un
d'extrêmement important est qu'il est
ailleurs il est extrêmement rajeuni là
je bois que la campagne lui donne un
peps extraordinaire c'est livio
rhabiller les qualités oratoires qu'on
ne connaissait pas il est il est certain
alors bon vous savez que moi j'habite
dans le bocage donc vous ne me ferez
jamais dire quelque chose je respecterai
la science c'est à dire que je ne
mentirai pas mais c'est vrai qu'
évidemment dans le bocage vendéen on a
évidemment de là comment dire une
certaine admiration pour philippe de
villiers et là je crois que il a il a
démontré évidemment une très grande
forme une très grande généré efficacité
il est certain que
philippe de villiers et jean frédéric
poisson osseux ou les deux ce sont les
deux qui ont créé et qui ont favorisé
l'émergence non pas d'eric zemmour mais
de la dynamique zemmour pour l'élection
présidentielle
guillaume pelletier donc le qui alors
que l'on voit justement derrière olivier
ubéda se prépare elle à la team et
l'arrivée de derrick d'eric zemmour
peut-être un commentaire d'ailleurs sur
les images qu'on est en train de voir
l'ue
alors on se dit que ma main sur le micro
dont je fais attention à ce que l'on
m'entende pendant que justement c'est
cette entrée de d'eric zemmour avec un
an je peux être sécuritaire également
ça vous inspire quoi justement c'est
toute cette mise en scène
des meetings d'eric zemmour écoutez je
crois qu'il a besoin de 2,2 de ne plus
être auprès des téléspectateurs
simplement le journaliste le débatteur
mais qu'il est une une carrure une image
je dirais d'un homme politique et si
possible de de son point de vue d'un
homme d'état donc ça ne paraît pas je
dirais étonnant qu'il y ait cela il y a
un côté chirac qui s'est révélée chez
zemmour donc on ne pouvait absolument
pas soupçonner on va essayer de les
regarder plein pot d'ailleurs je les
régimes m2 les volumes de nous les
montrer avec l'ambiance et on va
continuer de commenter
oui il est certain que moi j'avoue que
je faisais partie de ceux qui étaient
assez dubitatifs sur le fait qu'eric
zemmour est bien se transforme en
comment dire un orateur de meetings en
candidat sur le terrain il s'avère que
effectivement il est efficace alors est
ce que pour autant parce qu'il y avait
ritable engouement militant-es que cela
je dirais correspond à la réalité de
l'ensemble de la sociologie du pays ça
en revanche je crois que les militants
auraient dû des formes et des choses
c'est pas parce qu'il ya énormément de
monde dans les meetings c'est pas parce
qu'il ya une très grosse présence sur
les réseaux sociaux l'équipe je dirais
qu'il est au tour de samuel la faune qui
s'occupe des réseaux sociaux pour eric
zemmour est extrêmement efficace ça on
le savait avant même qu'ils ne le
fassent donc oui il est extrêmement
présent est l'un des plus présents sur
les réseaux sociaux mais pour autant ce
n'est pas nécessairement ce qui fait je
dirais les scores à l'élection parce que
sinon ça voudrait dire que ce serait
celui qui seraient partis plus tôt dans
la campagne qui aurait fait le plus de
meetings qui serait forcément élue banon
malheureusement c'est pas celui qui aura
rassemblé le plus de monde dans les
meetings qui est forcément élue c'est
peut-être injuste mais enfin mais enfin
malheureusement c'est malheureusement
c'est comme ça alors que l'hexagone donc
justement traverse
les l'assistance qui est qu'il accueille
donc allé là grand palais avant de
prendre la parole avec un petit peu plus
d'un quart d'heure de retard sur le
programme qui était prévu 16h15 c'est
est annoncée entre les cas par la
direction de la communication de la
campagne d'eric zemmour on va continuer
de suivre
ces instants avant la prise de parole
donc à lille et on continuera de de
commenter et puis posé un sartre être
quelques questions
qu'ils se posent sur les personnes qu'en
début mai les personnes aussi que l'on
n'a pas vu cet après midi
légalement toute cette question de
l'union ou de l'unité de la droite
eric zemmour donc ils s'approchent de la
scène puisque on voit les responsables
officiels de sa campagne c'est le signe
que ce n'est plus très loin jean
frédéric selon gilbert collard olivier
north donc l'on n'a pas entendu tout
bruno north pardon que l'on n'a pas
entendu tout à leur président du ceni et
laurence trochut à côté de philippe de
villiers
accolade à guillaume pelletier
laurence rochât qui est la fondatrice
donc dès à présent présidentes pardon du
mouvement conservateur qui est l'ancien
mouvement
sens commun
nombre de la manif pour tout ce qui
était au sein des républicains et
l'accolade à jacqueline moreau saf un
commentaire le disais tout à l'heure que
l'internaute nous disait tout à l'heure
qui se verrait bien voter pour chacune
moureaux c'est le se présenter aux
législatives il ya fort à parier en tous
les cas chaque internaute que elle le
soit
en tout cas on suivra cette campagne si
si c'est le cas
pendant que
eric zemmour montrent où je donne
quelques
commentaires
on va écouter dans l'ambiance
oui effectivement kriss kross tu l'as vu
jacqueline moreau qui était l'un des
premiers
un des premiers soutiens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs
peut être le prochain président de la
région le français ils veulent être pour
vous
merci d'accueillir monsieur eric le bour
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous leurs amis
quel plaisir d'être de retour à lille
quel plaisir d'être de retour sur cette
sphère du nord si humaine si sincère et
si chaleureuse quel plaisir
quel plaisir de venir en cours est de
toute mon équipe vous les avez écouté je
suis fier qu'il soit à mes côtés
aujourd'hui philippe gilbert guillaume
n'accepte jérôme jacqueline jean
frédéric jean
joachim
bruno laurence jacques
raja bas
et tous les autres merci
et
[Applaudissements]
et vous
et vous quel bonheur de vous retrouver
lille war dunkerquois lensois
valenciennois calaisien
décidément
j'aime les gens du nord leur franchise
leur solidité leur humilité leur toile
quelle terre de feu que cette terre du
nord quel peuple chaleureux que ce
peuple de géants quels au sommet que ce
plat pays qui est le vôtre
[Musique]
merci
merci de votre accueil aujourd'hui à
lille et avant tout je voudrais que nous
ayons ans sans une pensée pour cette
policière 9 24 ans grièvement blessé
hier à lille par un multi récidiviste
déjà connu par la police
[Musique]
nous apportons à cette jeune femme tout
notre soutien je veux également
je veux également remercier toutes les
forces de l'ordre qui nous protège merci
mesdames et messieurs
que celle que vous êtes nos grands nous
aujourd'hui
lille lille ville du lys son nom son
blason lille la couleur de ses frais et
la puissance de ses baies froid lille la
cité de vauban et de charles de gaulle
et de vos visages de la france du
travail de la france du mérite à travers
vous en cette ère de l'amour et de
labeur de charbon et de coron de courage
et de tissage je voudrais m'adresser
aujourd'hui à la france du travail lui
donner mans - l'espérance qu'elle attend
nous avons besoin plus que jamais de
rendre au travail son sens son salaire
et sa valeur
[Musique]
en quelques mois en quelques mois c'est
la quatrième fois que je viens chez vous
pour vous équipez vous comprends et vous
présenter ma vision de la france aimez
solutions pour les français face aux
épreuves que nous traverserons en
octobre dernier
j'étais venu déjà parlé du travail de
mairie de fierté d'industrie je veux
maintenant vous dire ce que nous allons
faire ensemble pour que demain pour que
dans un an pour que dans cinq ans dont
trente ans notre pays et nos enfants se
portent mieux un ami lillois m'a dit un
jour ici on a du coeur au labeur cette
formule est resté gravé dans ma mémoire
votre terre six ans malmené n'a pas
seulement donné à la nation nombre de
héros et tant de grands hommes vous avez
aussi apporté à la france des industries
magnifique de grands groupes florissants
des pme innovantes des entrepreneurs
audacieux mais ingénieur brillant et des
travailleurs solidaires longtemps
londres le nord fut la seule terre
d'industrie d'une france qui était alors
presque exclusivement un pays de paix
jean
longtemps le nom
le coeur industriel de la france
longtemps le nord russe est vert où
arrivaient en grand nombre des immigrés
venus d'abord de belgique et pluie
d'italie et de pologne
longtemps le nord du secteur ouvrier
français et immigrés se retrouver au
café et à l'église où les étrangers
adoptés sont rechigner la langue et le
mode de vie des français qu'ils
côtoyaient
longtemps
oui longtemps le nord cette terre ou
l'assimilation
permettait une véritable intégration un
véritable vivre ensemble où tous quels
que soient ses origines se retrouver
dans le même amour de la france de son
histoire de ses moeurs de sa sociabilité
où la culture ouvrière socialiste se
mêlait à l'amour de la patrie qui leur
permettait de vivre décemment et
d'élever leurs enfants dans la paix et
la dignité
au pouce
où tous se retrouver dans le même
respect du travail du mérite de l'effort
oui ici ici dans le nord on est les
héritiers de ces générations d'ouvriers
durs à la tâche qui ne ménageaient pas
leurs peines et leurs efforts oui ici on
ne recule pas devant les efforts alors
alors ici
alors
ici encore plus qu'ailleurs l'assistanat
est une insulte ici on se lève tôt le
matin et on peut se coucher le soir avec
le sentiment du devoir accompli
et je sais
je sais combien ici dans les classes les
plus populaires jusqu'aux classes
moyennes on déteste l'assistanat
quand on se lève
quand on se lève chaque matin à 5 heures
pour aller travailler quand on gagne
difficilement sa vie à la sueur de son
front on n'accepte pas que le voisin
vivre mieux que soi grâce à des aides
sociales sans avoir besoin
[Applaudissements]
notre civilisation est celle du travail
et du travail bien fait c'est à cela
qu'on reconnaît un français souvenons
nous de charles pays célébrant le goût
et le soin des travail et cette même
application de la rampe aiodm chaises et
du bâtisseur de cathédrale à des siècles
d'écart prouvant dans le travail à la
fois la réalisation de m et celle de
leurs ouvrages
c'est là notre trésor notre patrimoine
notre capitale chaque pomme à ce rapport
particulier mon travail les américains
c'est le reste va et du concret
les allemands c'est le sens de l'équipe
les français c'est l'honneur oui
oui
[Musique]
l'honneur du travail bien fait qui relie
l'ouvrier est le patron dans le nord
comme en vendée philippe de villiers
avec cette histoire extraordinaire que
tu m'a raconté l'autre jour un
entrepreneur enraciné partageons tous
avec ses salariés jusqu'au football du
dimanche lorsqu'il se met sous les
ordres de son ouvrier devenu son
capitaine sur le terrain un jour les
actionnaires décident de le chasser
l'argent n'entre pas assez vite à leur
goût la chine produit moins propre et
plus et pluie le patron est débarqué
alors pour la première fois de leur vie
les ouvriers font grève scandalisé est
terminée les actionnaires doivent céder
le patron est de retour sous les
applaudissements de ses débuts
[Applaudissements]
oui
oui n'en déplaise pour partisans de la
lutte des classes notre capital c'est le
travail et le travail notre capitale
ensemble inséparables non délocalisables
face à la folle lutte des classes et
l'injuste loi de la jungle je serai le
président de la réconciliation des
classes le président qui réunira
l'entrepreneur et le travailleur
nous ne sommes pas
ces utopistes qui rêvent de la fin du
travail et du revenu universel ni de ces
socialistes qui abandonne les ouvriers
est un sport les 35 heures qui
appauvrissent la france et les français
emmanuel macron qui s'est présenté comme
l'homme du progrès et qui n'a rien fait
progresser notre pays
[Musique]
vous savez
vous savez mieux que personne ici quels
sont les ravages d'une société où le
travail et les prises et où les
travailleurs furent remplacés au nom de
la mondialisation heureuse et de
l'immigration où l'assistanat paye mieux
que l'artisanat où les usines ferment
quand les parachutes dorés
de tout cela nous allons parler ensemble
aujourd'hui alors pour aborder les
sujets aussi importants pour l'avenir de
notre nation pour le quotidien de chacun
d'entre nous je suis heureux de vous
voir aussi nombreux
huit mille personnes mais thani
non
en vo nord aussi non vous me fait chaud
au coeur mais sachez quand même que vous
avez
contrarier quelqu'un
quelqu'un
quelqu'un d'important ici paraît-il
mais chère vallée
bah oui on est en ville à lille vous
fait de la peine à martine aubry c'est
pas bien ce qu'on fait
martine aubry la maire emploi comme
l'ont surnommé ses amis socialistes
votre très chère mère qui dit que je ne
suis pas le bienvenu dans sa ville de
lille bah oui
c'est sa ville de lille
robin lui appartient 7000 voyons
[Applaudissements]
et
oui martine aubry qui appelle les
antifas cette racaille d'extrême gauche
à manifester
martine aubry qui rêve suscité des
violences contre nous accuse ensuite
d'être responsables de ces violences
toujours les mêmes méthodes chez les
gauchistes mais sommes-nous violent mes
amis
[Musique]
on nous la violence
nous voulons la paix
alors on votre nom mes chers amis
je veux dit à madame aubry
non madame les lillois ne vous
appartiennent pas
les lillois font livres libres de faire
ce qu'ils veulent libre de penser ce
qu'ils veulent libre de dire ce qu'ils
veulent pour leur pays libres de
dénoncer ce que vous vous refusez de
voir
carabine
à lille et dans toute la région
l'islamisation se répondent et je n'ai
pas beaucoup entendu martine aubry sur
ce sujet
madame aubry la grande républicaine qui
n'a rien à dire dans des quartiers
entiers échappe à la république dont les
lois sont remplacés par la charia
martine aubry la grande prêtresse de la
laïcité qui reste muette dans des cités
entières de sa métropole lilloise
bascule dans l'intégrisme musulman
martin
martine aubry la féministe qui ne trouve
rien à redire quand des femmes
musulmanes exigent et obtiennent les
horaires de piscine aménagée dans sa
ville et quant au voile
et quand on voit les petite fille de 6
ans à roubaix à
à roubaix
l'afghanistan à deux heures de paris et
a valu de chez nous
[Applaudissements]
il y a il y a deux semaines la chaîne m6
diffusait un reportage sur
l'islamisation de roubaix je suppose que
vous l'avez vu
vous avez vu ces poupées son visage vous
avez vu ses restaurants ses restaurants
où les femmes sont parqués dans des
boxes ces écoles coraniques subventionné
où l'on voit des filles est de 16 ans
vous avez vu vous avez vu ce que
finalement vous saviez mieux que
personne mais ce soir-là à une heure de
grande écoute la vérité a éclaté au
visage de tous ceux qui voulaient encore
la nuit et la terrible vérité celle que
nous connaissons celle que selon les
sondages
67% des français traîne c'est que la
dire que la france s'islamise à grande
vitesse
tél
quelle tristesse oui quelle tristesse
pour des villes comme roubaix dans cette
cité ouvrière on ne trouve plus beaucoup
d' usine mais on trouve beaucoup de
mosquées on peine à trouver des cafés
mais on trouve beaucoup de boucherie
halal on n'a plus beaucoup de librairies
françaises mais on tombe sur des
librairies islamiques on aperçoit plus
beaucoup de jupes mais on voit beaucoup
de niqab on cherche la france et on ne
la trouve plus la france
la france disparaît sous les yeux
effrayés et français des roubaisiens qui
n'ont pas fui qui n'ont pas pu fuir
et on apprend de pluie
et on apprend d'autrui que les courageux
journalistes qui ont tourné ce reportage
sont maintenant menacés peu et leurs
familles de de décapitation de viol il
doit vivre désormais sous protection
policière
parce qu'ils ont osé vous montrer la
réalité
je vis
je vis la même chose je sais ce que
c'est je me suis habitué depuis des
années mais c'est un scandale c'est un
scandale que les français s'habituent à
vivre ainsi dans leur propre pays
alors
[Applaudissements]
alors bien sûr nos bonnes âmes de droite
comme de gauche
relativisez détourne le regard il ne
faut surtout pas faire de vagues oui
bien sûr pendant ce temps les idéologues
de gauche ont toujours la main sur le
coeur
pour jean luc mélenchon tout net à faire
oui pour lui tout net à faire que de
pauvreté et de misère pour lui les choix
individuels n'existe pas l'histoire
n'existe pas la culture n'existe pas et
la démographie n'existe pas non plus la
dé la france la délinquance est à cause
de la pauvreté la criminalité
c'est la pauvreté
la saleté
la pauvreté
l'islamisation la pauvreté toujours
[Applaudissements]
à
autre fille s'est fait agresser par un
étranger à contre la pauvreté
notre mère s'est fait cambrioler la
pauvreté
kim avait saccagé la pauvreté la
pauvreté toujours mais encore seul et
unique explication à tous les problèmes
du pays
ce soir
ce soir je veux vous le dire dans ce
fief de la gauche française mes chers
amis la vision socialiste de la pauvreté
est une vision odieuse selon ces
politiciens de gauche la pauvre démène
nécessairement à la bella compte si l'on
est faux alors forcément on aurait envie
de voler de billets de détruire et
pourquoi pas de tuer
cette théorie est affreuse elle est une
insulte à tous ces gens modestes qui se
sont toujours fait un devoir de rester
honnête de rester droit parfois
tellement plus droits que les riches et
les puissants
oui
c'est une insulte pour tous ceux qui
refusent de brandir l'injustice de la
vie pour l'arabe encore plus injuste
songez aux innombrables procès de
condition modeste qui grâce à leur
intelligence leur pouvoir leur travail
grâce à leurs propres mérites ont réussi
à s'en sortir
amener des victimes et certains même à
devenir riche et à créer des empires
voilà nos traditions du monde voilà
notre modèle
buck taubira mélenchon de valérie
pécresse à emmanuel manu voyez
voyez la valse des grands bourgeois qui
fantasme sur un prolétariat d'immigrés
qu'ils ne connaissent pas que distille
il faut plus d'argent et on arrêtera la
délinquance
la réalité
oui la réalité mes amis c'est que ces
quartiers sont tout sauf abandonné ils
sont gavés d'argent public et de
prestations sociales ils sont en vérité
privilégiées la réalité c'est que la
véritable pauvreté beaucoup de français
la connaissent la ville et la suisse il
vit c'est que lorsque l'argent vient à
manquer lorsque les dettes s'accumulent
et lorsque les fins de mois deviennent
difficiles voire impossibles
lorsqu'on a travaillé toute la semaine
et qu'à la fin il ne reste plus un
centime lorsqu'on s'est épuisé à la
tâche et qu'on ne mange pas toujours à
sa faim lorsqu'on est une mère seule et
qu'on doit travailler
toujours plus parce qu'il faut payer la
garde des petits
lorsqu'on connaît les difficultés à se
soigner à éduquer ses enfants à soutenir
c'est par ces angoisses qui polluent le
quotidien et qui cache l'existence ses
angoisses je ne les ragon jamais mais je
les ai moi même connu quand j'étais
enfant j'ai connu à 10 12 ans les
huissiers qui frappe à la fois j'ai
connu l'obligation d'aller vivre chez
mes grands parents parce que mon père ne
pouvait plus payer le loyer j'avais la
chance d'avoir un père travailleur
courageux qui s'est toujours relevée qui
s'est sacrifiée qui m'a permis d'arriver
là où il est
com
comme vous le savez je sillonne la pop
depuis des mois je vois venir à moi tant
de français qui nous confie monsieur
zemmour fait quelque chose pour nous on
n'en peut plus à ces jeunes à ces jeunes
de 20 ans qui me disent j'ai coupé mon
chauffage je n'ai plus de quoi le payer
à ses fans seul qui souffrirent je ne
vais plus voir ma mère à la maison de
retraite l'essence est trop chère oui
oui j'ai croisé souvent le désarroi et
parfois la misère l'indignation est
souvent la colère ils me le disent je
les enfants on dirait de là haut ils ne
vivent pas dans la même économie et que
nous ils ne disent pas dans le même pays
que nous il nous parle de statistiques
mais nous on vit de précarité à ils sont
loin ils sont si loin de la france vous
mes amis quand vous connaissez ces
difficultés pour esthétique vous rester
honnête pour rester fier ou chercher des
solutions vous ne fraude est pas ou ne
dégradent et pas beau logement vous
éduquer correctement vos enfants vous ne
brûlez pas des écoles ni la voiture du
voisin vous ne cassez pas oui chez vous
on ne casse pas
je ne voulais pas casser les construire
vous ne voulez pas être raciste et vous
voulez travailler vous ne voulez pas
l'aumône pour voulait vivre dignement de
votre travail je le sais je vous en ai
je vous réponds et je veux vous répondre
différemment des politiciens qui vous
parle car aujourd'hui
tout le monde ne parle que du pouvoir
d'achat tous les candidats répète en
boucle qu'ils sont le candidat du
pouvoir d'achat qu'avec eux on va prend
du pouvoir d'achat comme si vous l'avez
garder quelque part je les écoute oui je
les écoute depuis des semaines est en
réalité de la droite jusqu'à la gauche
ils disent tous la même chose ils ne
disent rien que vous promet-il au coeur
des cadeaux
[Musique]
des chèques des déductions des
pourcentages des barèmes des tours de
magie de l'argent public de l'argent
théorie de l'argent magie je vais vous
dire quelque chose mais a mis l'argent
magique n'existe pas l'argent public
l'argent théorie l'argent gratuit leurs
belles promesses tout cela n'existe pas
ils vont ruiner et ils le savent chacune
de ces mesures censées lutter contre la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat va faire
chuter votre pouvoir d'achat pourquoi
parce que l'argent qui promettent de
vous donner ils vont vous le volet cet
argent qu ils vous promettent c'est le
mot chaque euro qui vous font miroiter
pour demain se trouve aujourd'hui dans
votre porte monnaie ils sont en rade
vous achetez avec votre propre argent
il vous
ils vous appâter avec des chèques
cadeaux mais c'est vous qui passerait à
la caisse vous payerez cache tout ce qu
il prétend que vous offrir et à la fin
non seulement vous n'y aurez bien gagner
mais pousse y aurait perdu et beaucoup
car cette redistribution encourue va
coûter une fortune au pays et là encore
c'est vous qui la financera
c'est du racket d'élise est enchantée
l'argent public c'est votre argent plus
d'argent public c'est moins d'argent
pour vous alors regardons la vérité
économique en face en réalité personne
dans cette campagne ne se demande
vraiment ce que veut dire pouvoir
d'achat alors
alors nous allons nous demander ensemble
qu'est ce que le pouvoir d'achat le
pouvoir d'achat c'est l'argent qui vous
reste qu'on les arrête de tout reprendre
le pouvoir d'achat
c'est ce que vous gardez quand vous avez
payé les charges qui pèsent sur votre
salaire la tva sur propose d'achat les
taxes votre plein d'essence votre info
sur le revenu votre redevance télé aux
impôts locaux votre taxe foncière le
pouvoir d'achat c'est ce que les tables
viable blessé quand ils vous laissent
quelque chose
c'est ce qui vous permet de payer notre
loyer
loyer aux vêtements aux repas votre
médecin vos médicaments votre voiture
est l'essence de votre voiture vos
loisirs quand vous le coupez tout
absolument tout le pouvoir d'achat
reconnaît bien cela chers amis c'est
l'argent que l'état ne vous compte pas
c'est ce que les technocrates de bercy
dans leur grande générosité et leur
immense vais vous laisse après vous
avoir essoré
le pouvoir d'achat c'est ce qui reste de
votre vie donc on vous laisse être autre
chose qu'un contribuable le pouvoir
d'achat c'est ce petit bourg est vous
cesser de financer une bureaucratie
écrasante et millions d'étrangers qui ne
travaillent pas l'assistanat généralisé
l'endettement un foot pour les blés ta
lettre tu repères aux pays pauvres du
monde entier nous sommes le peuple le
plus taxé au mont houy
[Musique]
il faut se le répéter sans cesse mes
amis matin midi et soir car on a du mal
à y voir nous sommes le peuple le plus
taxé au monde riche riche comme
appartenant à la classe moyenne nous
sommes tous les plus taxés au monde nous
avons les taxes et impôts les plus
élevés du monde nous travaillons près de
la moitié de l'année pour financer un
état devenu obèse qui dépense sans
compter c'est normal ce n'est pas son
argent c'est le veau
ou le prendre
vous le coffre lui fait aucun mal le
dépenser encore moins il est tellement
facile de dépenser l'argent des autres
le pouvoir d'achat c'est ce qui vous
reste quand vous cesser de payer pour
l'aide médicale d'état les étrangers
quand vous cesser de payer pour que des
fraudeurs touchent des allocations qui
ne devrait pas toucher pour vous cesser
de financer les places de prison pour
15000 l'étranger c'est quand vous avez
déjà donné la moitié de votre paye pour
des dépenses folles pour que des
terroristes profitent du rsa ou du
chômage pour financer un énième plan
banlieues
le pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir d'achat
c'est ce qui vous reste quand vous
cesser de subventionner des milliers
d'associations de gauche qui ne cesse
d'attaquer l'état et rêvent de détruire
la liberté d'expression dans notre pays
c'est quand cessé de payer pour des
usines à gaz technocratique pour un
millefeuille administratif
toujours plus épais pour des
administrations devenue absurde quand
elles ne rendent plus de services
publics alors
alors
forcément quand vous avez fini de donner
ce que vous gagnez à ces gens qui ne
vous diront jamais merci ces gens qui
méprisent le travailleur le salarié
créateur l'entrepreneur et qui vivent de
votre argent forcément quand vous avez
vous fini de payer
votre pouvoir d'achat est faible de plus
en plus faible votre pouvoir d'achat se
réduit chaque année davantage et vous en
avez assez et moi aussi j'en ai assez
sauvé
sauver le pouvoir d'achat pourquoi c'est
une urgence absolue car un pouvoir
d'achat fragile c'est une vie fragile un
pouvoir d'achat au rabais ce sont des
choix qui polluent le quotidien de toute
une famille c'est devoir choisir entre
préparer les pros ménages est en panne
et faire la révision de la voiture c'est
devoir choisir entre le soutien scolaire
de son aîné et le nouveau membre de la
petite dernière oui on en est là oui on
vous donne le choix entre le moins bien
et le pire oui tous et il aime
obscurcissent votre quotidien et le gaz
la vie
pourtant
connais vous bien il paraît que notre
pouvoir d'achat a augmenté et vous ne le
saviez pas
c'est pourtant c'est pourtant ce que
proclame fièrement les technocrates de
bercy et les fonctionnaires de bruxelles
depuis des années vous savez ce sont les
mêmes qui nous disent qu'il n'ya pas
d'insécurité mais un sentiment d'assez
plus
est
la baisse du pouvoir d'achat alors
qu'est ce que c'est un sentiment
d'appauvrissement
les mêmes politiciens les mêmes
technocrates avaient tenté de nous faire
croire que le passage à l'euro à b
améliorer le pouvoir d'achat ben voyons
[Applaudissements]
l'esbm nous affirme aujourd'hui que
l'inflation ne repart pas que la hausse
des prix n'est que provisoire ben voyons
alors
alors mes chers amis pour augmenter
votre pouvoir d'achat bleus comprenez
maintenant il n'ya pas mille méthode
seuls trois solutions s'offrent à nos
trois solutions connues de toutes nos
élites mais jamais mis en oeuvre par
manque de courage et parlons donne écrit
trois solutions pour enfin reconquérir
le pouvoir d'achat des français la
preuve
la première de ces solutions chers amis
les politiciens et les technocrates ne
veulent pas qu'on en parle alors il n'en
parle pas du tout vous il en parle à
moitié mais le peuple sait à quel point
nous en avons besoin alors oui nous
allons enfin cesser de gaspiller
l'argent public car l'argent public
c'est rod argent
c'est autant d'argent que nous allons
arrêter de boucan
la deuxième solution mes amis vous la
connaissez j'en ai déjà parlé et je vous
le redis nous allons arrêter de financer
notre propre remplacement car lui aussi
mais qui n'en sont pas propres
et cet argent nous allons cesser de vous
le prend et enfin c'est essentiel et
c'est ce que vous attendez nous allons
enfin
récompensé le travail et le mérite
l'argent
[Musique]
l'argent qu'ils ont gagné à la sueur de
votre front ne doit pas atterrir dans je
ne sais quelle caisse publique mais sur
votre compte en banque
oui
mes chers amis je veux d'abord que
l'état soit l'allié des familles alliées
des salariés l'allié des retraités
l'allié de tous ceux qui veulent s'en
sortir je veux que l'état soit au
service des français
mais pour cela
il va falloir que notre état cesse enfin
de gaspiller notre argent nous sommes
les seuls dans cette campagne
présidentielle nous préoccuper de cet
immense gâchis et cela est logique nous
sommes les seuls qui pensons aux
prochaines générations car je ne vous le
dirai jamais assez il n'y a pas d'argent
public il n'y a pas d'argent magique
l'argent de l'état c'est notre argent
c'est votre argent
je serai le candidat qui mettra fin au
gaspillage de l'argent du contribuable
de mélenchon à macron ils veulent tous
vous ruiner mais l'argent gaspillé
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui manquera à nos
enfants demain la responsabilité c'est
savoir dans chaque rapport et dans
chaque décision politique que la
richesse ne vient jamais de l'état mais
qu'elle vient des français que tous les
matins se lèvent tôt pour aller
travailler ma doctrine éclaire ma
doctrine est clair
l'impôt doit servir aux services publics
l'impôt doit servir aux français et la
peau doit être le levier de l'état au
service de la france
cela signifie
cela signifie que nous allons arrêter de
prendre leur argent aux français pour
financer des dépenses que l'état ne
devrait pas financer vous voulez les
exemples de ce que nous allons arrêter
de financer écoutez bien
écoutez bien et rendez vous en pleine
crise ducobu le gouvernement d'emmanuel
matin à trouver le moyen de faire un
chèque de 140 millions d'euros
pour aider le développement
de la chine
oui de la chine
le développement de la deuxième
puissance économique du monde oui mes
amis vous avez bien entendu les impôts
que vous payez sert à donner de l'argent
de poche à la deuxième puissance
économique du monde et cela alors que
nous manquions de masques et de
respirateurs pour sauver nos malades
mais annie emmanuel macron prodon que
l'argent dans votre poche pour le donner
un pays qui a concurrencé avec férocité
vos industries aux ateliers de tissage
de dentelle vaut mille évoquons
fourneaux combien d'entreprises ont dû
fermer à cause de cette concurrence
déloyale
combien d'emplois sacrifiés combien
d'ouvriers au chômage et il faudrait en
plus aider la chine encore une fois il
est facile pour eux de dépenser l'argent
des autres le vôtre
un autre exemple encore un autre exemple
au hasard
prenons l'audiovisuel public
j'avais dit au hasard
nous payons tous ici cette redevance
télé évidemment nous serions tous
d'accord pour financer un service public
de qualité mais
mais la france et les français n'ont pas
besoin de médias de gauche qui les
détestent ils n'ont pas besoin de
financer la propagande immigrationniste
box et cologna de france inter
qui n'hésitera insulter les français qui
le phosphate au monde
[Applaudissements]
bon
nous arrêtons donc de prendre l'argent
des français pour financer ces médias ce
sera une taxe d'au moins et une économie
de 138 euros pour chaque foyer
endémique au
l'audiovisuel public nous pousse chaque
année plus cher que nos prisons ces 3 2
puis 6 milliards d'euros que vous payez
pour ces médias de gauche quand nous
payons 3,3 milliards pour nos prisons
problème alors que tant de délinquance
ond gore faute de place
aujourd'hui on préfère financer des
programmes télé plutôt que d'assurer la
sécurité des français au jeu c'est les
bobos vont hurler les gauchistes heavy
de cet argent public on s'indigner mais
ce n'est pas mon sujet on parle ici de
justice on parle ici de l'argent des
prophètes et on parle ici de leur
pouvoir d'achat
jusqu'à quand
jusqu'à quand l'état va-t-il utiliser
l'argent que vous gagnez en travaillant
tous les jours à des dépenses qui
choquerait plus de la moitié des
français ce n'est pas cela la justice ce
n'est pas cela la démocratie
les exemples sont tellement nombreux que
nous pourrions y passer toute la journée
chacune de ces dépenses folles chacune
de ces dépenses inutiles c'est à chaque
fois des plaisirs appelons vous enlève
des besoins auxquels vous ne pouvait
plus subvenir des achats que vous
sacrifiez je vais donc vous annoncer la
méthode que nous suivrons sans jamais
reculer d'un seul bas dès le premier
jour de mon quinquennat nous
commencerons à dresser la liste
exhaustive de tous les moyens par
lesquels l'état réduit votre pouvoir
d'achat
[Applaudissements]
nous
sans exception une immense réflexion de
tout ce qui fait de nous le pays de
taxer le plus imposé et le plus pur en
pratique du monde occidental avec l'aide
d'entrepreneurs et d'économistes nous
lancerons la plus grande réforme de
l'état depuis le général de gaulle
pendant cinq ans nous abolirons tout ce
qui vous détruit
cinq ans pour sauver définitivement
repas pouvoir d'achat cinq ans pour
reconquérir la prospérité française cinq
ans pour démontrer qu'impossible n'est
pas français cinq ans qui marqueront à
tout jamais
[Applaudissements]
non
nous serons d'une sévérité absolue dans
le diagnostic comme dans nos décisions
et les fonctionnaires utile dévoué impec
et il saute sinon moi pourrons enfin
accomplir leur mission car ils sont je
tiens à le dire eux aussi les victimes
de la bureaucratie elle les pompes elle
les noix sans elle il serait aimé par le
peuple parce qu'il serait plus
disponible et efficace que jamais ils
seront fiers et nous serons fiers
chez un ami
pour conclure sur ce grave sujet méfiez
vous des candidats qui vous disent qu'il
suffira d'un choc de simplification pour
régler le problème s'ils prennent le
pouvoir il n'y aura pas de
simplification parce qu'il n'y aura pas
de choc non ils ne toucheront pas à
bureaux cratie parce qu'ils ont vienne
et parce qu'elle est leur meilleur allié
le shop de simplification de valérie
pécresse c'est la reprise d'une idée de
françois hollande c'est une idée de
purau prague la fin de la bureaucratie
la fin des dépenses inutiles ce n'est
pas une ligne dans un programme
électoral c'est la méthode de tout mon
quinquennat
parmi
parmi ces dépenses folles mes amis vous
le savez
tous les français le sam il y a le
financement de l'immigration oui mes
amis sauver le pouvoir d'achat des
français s'est également arrêté de
financer l'immigration sur votre dos
c'est arrêter de dilapider l'argent pris
dans vos poches même quand elles sont
vides pour nourrir le monde entier
dès notre arrivée au pouvoir nous allons
cesser de prendre qu'aux français les
milliards d'euros consacrés chaque année
à l'accueil et à l'entretien des
millions d'étrangers qui vivent sur
notre sol nous allons
nous allons
nous allons retrouver notre modèle
social pour qu'il redevienne
véritablement
français car notre modèle social n'est
plus capable de lutter contre la misère
parce que tout le tiers monde vient en
profiter notre modèle social laisse des
familles à l'abandon et pénalise nos
entreprises pendant qu'il nourrit des
islamistes notre modèle social et rendre
les classes moyennes abandonne les
catégories populaires tandis qu'il
arrose les cités chaque année les
demandeurs d'asile coûte un milliard
trois cents millions d'euros au français
soit prêt
soit près de 830 euros par mois pour
chacun d'entre eux c'est plus que la
retraite d'autres temps de nos acteurs
qui ont trimé une boucle orbi pour
nourrir notre pays
[Applaudissements]
savez vous
savez-vous qu'en plus d'un hébergement
gratuit et de soins gratuits
nous donnons à chaque demandeur d'asile
pendant prés donnant une carte bancaire
crédité de 430 euros par mois afin que
celui ci puisse dépenser tranquillement
l'argent de pause
tout cela tout cela sans qu'il le
travail évidemment je mettrai fin aux
demandes d'asile déposées sur notre sol
et je réserverai la ville à quelques
dizaines d'individus
oui
je réserverai la ville à quelques
dizaines d'individus les vrais
combattants pour la liberté et non à des
dizaines de milliers comme aujourd'hui
ce sera
1,305 1 milliard 300 millions d'euros
que l'état arrêtera de vous prendre
chaque année
par l'ons
parlons d'une autre dépense publique que
je vais vous épargner mes amis chaque
année les mineurs les mineurs non
accompagnés
coûte 2 milliard d'euros aux français
oui cinquante mille euros par mineur ou
étrangers vous avez bien entendu chacun
de ces mineurs isolés nous coûte plus de
4000 euros par mois là encore pour nous
remercier de notre bon coeur et de notre
main tendue ces mêmes mineurs isolés ont
commis rien qu'à paris 5000 actes de
délinquance en 2020 des agressions des
vols qui pourrissent le quotidien des
élections mais
mais comme ils sont mineurs ils ne vont
pas en prison --dont qu'il recommence je
mettrai pas à cette injustice pour moi
pour moi
pour moi la justice c'est prendre ces
deux milliards et les donner aux
français de nos communes rurales qui
font des enfants c'est pour cela que je
donnerais 10000 euros par naissance d'un
français dans une famille rurale
dix mille dix mille euros pour un
français qui naît dans ces communes qui
se dépeuple qu'est ce que cela
représente
face aux cinquante mille euros que nous
dépensons chaque année pour chaque
mineur m'isoler clandestins
cette mesure
cette mesure n'est pas un chèque cadeau
c'est de la justice c'est de l'argent
que nous cesserons de donner à des
clandestins du monde entier pour les
donner à nouveau patriotes qui en ont
besoin
ses préférés
c'est préférer le politique de la
campagne à notre folle politique de la
ville c'est favoriser enfin la natalité
dans nos campagnes plutôt que
l'explosion démographique en novembre
lieu encore une autre dépense
encore no autre dépense à vous épargner
dès mon arrivée au pouvoir cherche à
nous chaque année un clandestin qui ne
travaillent pas qui ne paye pas de
charges sociales qui ne payent pas
d'impôt coûte en moyenne
2600 euros au système de santé français
grâce à la m merci madame aubry merci
merci merci pour cette belle réforme qui
a coûté des milliards au procès depuis
plus de 20 ans pendant ce temps la
moitié de la france est devenue un
désert médical où il faut attendre des
mois pour avoir un rendez vous chez le
dentiste où il faut faire des heures de
route pour accouché dans une maternité
alors
alors je supprimerai live
oui
je supprimerai me et son beau-frère
mille médecins salariés en urgence pour
nos départements qui manque de médecins
c'est bien la moindre des choses pour un
pays qui racontait avoir le meilleur
système de santé du monde
et
et je ne vous parle pas du rsa et des
allocations en tout genre actuellement
en france tenez vous bien
55% des étrangers extra européens en âge
de travailler
sont tout simplement inactif
ce qui leur laisse apparemment le temps
de faire des enfants puisque selon
l'insee les immigrés représentent à
elles seules 30% de toutes les
naissances française 30
en résumé en résumé nous finançons leur
arrivée nous finançons l'entretien des
banlieues qu'ils ont saccagés nous
finançons leurs traits de vie bref nous
finançons notre grand remplacement au
prix de notre grande et classement
[Applaudissements]
oui mes amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il mes amis
les charges que vous subissez sur vos
fiches de paye finance aussi
l'immigration de masse je vais vous
raconter une histoire
l'histoire de stéphanie la belle
stéphanie a drop elle est diplômée d'un
ca fait de vente elle travaille en
cinéma
depuis des années stéphanie sollicite un
logement hlm mais
elle ne l'a jamais obtenu alors
alors stéphanie vit à l'année dans une
caravane
stéphanie faute de logement social doit
dormir chaque nuit dans un conflit quand
un journaliste l'interrogeant
cette femme fière réponse
j'ai abandonné la recherche pour les hlm
je ne me plains même on a l'impression
qu'il n'y en a plus pour les émigrés que
pour nous pour les maisons pour les
appartements ils sont toujours
prioritaires
l'histoire l'histoire de stéphanie mes
amis c'est l'histoire de tellement nous
français pendant ce temps 20%
d'étrangers occupent nos logements
sociaux nous disons stop ça suffit
la fête est finie nous réserverons nos
logements sociaux aux français oui
oui
le logement est l'une des défenses les
plus lourds et il n'y a aucune raison de
toujours favoriser les eaux nous
n'accepterons plus on nous fasse les
poches pour nourrir ceux qui ne font pas
d'efforts ce qui souvent nous haïssent
et ceux qui nous méprisent nous
couperons les aides sociales aux
étrangers extra européens
rsa
allocations familiales aides au logement
en tout ce sont plus de 20 milliards
d'euros par an on arrêtera de vous
prendre nous allégerons ainsi les
charges qui pèsent sur les salaires des
français les plus modestes il n'est plus
admissible que votre fiche de paye
viennent financer l'assistanat des
étrangers
[Applaudissements]
les eaux
nous allons donc nous allons donc
augmenter votre salaire sans desservir
vos entreprises nous allons augmenter
votre salaire net en préservant le
salaire brut pour ceux qui touchent un
semis cette somme représentera jusqu'à
105 euros par mois c'est un véritable
13e mois qui doit permettre à des
millions de français déclarent seaal en
raison de leur famille
oui
je pense aux familles a le pouvoir
d'achat est souvent une préoccupation
collective celle angoisses des parents
pour leur sang français la difficulté à
fonder un foyer et même parfois ce sont
des tensions dans un groupe alors oui
nous mettrons en place la bourse de
naissance j'ai déjà évoqué pour nos
familles rurales mais pour toutes les
familles des classes moyennes partout en
france celle qu'on n'oublie à chaque
fois celles qui sont suffisamment riches
pour supporter toutes les augmentations
mais jamais assez fort pour obtenir les
allocations oui pour ces familles
oui
oui mes amis pour ces familles je
doublerai le plateau du quotient
familial et je rendrai les allocations
familiales universelles comme c'était le
cas avant la réforme du gouvernement de
france dans l'ordre
car oui
oui il ya des familles de la classe
moyenne qui ont un emploi qui vend un
logement mais qui souffre quand même il
faut aussi laisser des jeunes
n'abandonnerait pas les classes moyennes
et beaucoup de familles
savent rien qu'ici même quand ils ont
quitté le nid familial
nous devons toujours aidé financièrement
nos enfants surtout s'ils font des
études mais quand on fait partie de la
classe moyenne comme d'habitude on a le
droit à rien alors avec nous les choses
vont changer les élèves issus des
classes moyennes auront enfin accès aux
bourses de scolarité que ce soit pour
l'université ou pour les grandes écoles
oui
oui nous devons aider nos étudiants vous
êtes nombreux dans la salle et je veux
que nous vous appelons mission
[Applaudissements]
et
car
car depuis deux ans vous êtes l'écran
sacrifiés de la politique d' emmanuel
macron deux ans loin de vos familles -
de vos amis si souvent contraints à la
visio derrière votre ordinateur vous
avez eu de quoi devenir fou vous avez
manon et pour nombre d'entre vous les
galères ont déjà commencé
la difficulté à payer le loyer à jongler
entre l'université bilgi la prépa ou bts
et un petit boulot à côté et parfois
même à vous nourrir vous êtes
vous aide
vous êtes l'avenir de la france et
préparer l'avenir c'est justement
soutenir les familles c'est soutenir
toutes ces familles qui prépare la
france de demain et des l'epani ce n'est
pas seulement aider les jeunes parents
c'est aussi penser aux anciens je pense
notamment à ces retraités veufs et bugs
qui vivent avec deux misérables retraite
et qui survivent difficilement avec
l'aide de leurs enfants et de leurs
petits enfants pour celles qui ont perdu
leur mari ceux qui ont perdu leurs
femmes et qui doivent survivre avec la
moitié d'une retraite nous augmenterons
les pensions de réversion à 75 %
car
car je trouve je trouve qu'il n'est pas
juste qu'à la douleur de la mort d'un
être cher s'ajoute la crainte de la
misère à bonnut au delà de 70 ans une
femme sur deux vit seule en découpant
sur les 4 millions 400 mille personnes
qui sont titulaires d'une pension de
reversions 4 millions sont des femmes il
n'est pas juste que des femmes se
retrouvent dans la difficulté alors
qu'elles font non seulement travailler
mais aussi voué leur vie à l'éducation
de leurs enfants je mettrai fin à cette
injustice
oui
oui car nous défendrons la justice et
pour tous les français
défendre la justice c'est enfin
revaloriser le travail car à la fin des
fins votre pouvoir d'achat c'est le
fruit de votre travail quand on vous
laisse vivre de votre travail pour
l'état cesse de vous prendre ce que vous
allez gagner quand votre patron peut
vous rémunéré à la hauteur des efforts
que vous avez fourni sans se demander si
la moitié partira dans les caisses de
l'état
car à la fin des fins oui votre pouvoir
d'achat à la fin du mois c'est celui que
vous avez mérité pour quatre semaines
des ports et parfois de sacrifices pour
30 jours de rigueur et de sérieux alors
oui nous voulons que le travail paie ce
n'est que justice oui nous voulons que
le travail paye mieux mieux que les
revenus de l'assistanat ce n'est que
justice
nous voulons
et nous voulons qu'il fait et nous
voulons qu'il fait tout de suite et pas
après je ne sais quel mécanisme de
redistribution qui consiste à vous
rendre l'argent que vous avez tout de
suite pour vous le rendre si vous cochez
les bonnes cases car pour nous car pour
nous il n'y a pas de contre à pouvoir
bien gagner sa vie à subvenir aux
besoins de sa famille oui travailler
plus pour gagner plus était un excellent
bras si les we
l'exonération de charges et la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires était une excellente
idée
[Applaudissements]
oh
en
en abolissant en abolissant cette mesure
pleine de bon sens du quinquennat
sarkozy la gauche et françois hollande
ont donné un exemple typique des mauvais
travers de la classe politique supprimer
ce que ses prédécesseurs au fait de
mieux qui tu as trahi et les
travailleurs français jusqu'à ses
propres électeurs nous nous ne sommes
pas des politiciens nous ne sommes pas
comme eux nous acceptons ce qui a été
fait de bien avant nous alors nous
rétablirons exonération totale de
charges et la défiscalisation totale des
heures supplémentaires pour que les
français qui souhaitent travailler plus
calme
ainsi
ils dépenseront plus il est pas non ils
investiront ils porteront davantage des
fruits de leur travail
nous voulons aussi
soutenir ces millions de français qui
prennent tous les matins leur voiture
pour se rendre à leur travail
je suis sûr que vous êtes nombreux à
être concernés aujourd'hui et que vous
serez d'accord avec moi pour nous pour
vous la voiture n'est pas un choix la
voiture est une obligation vous êtes
ouvriers vous êtes employé vous
travaillez dans un hôpital ou un
supermarché non vous n'allez pas prendre
votre vélo parcourir les kilomètres ne
s'est pas de votre entreprise de votre
usine ou de votre atelier depuis
plusieurs semaines le passage à la pompe
à essence est de plus en plus douloureux
des prix s'envolent des amours des taxes
des taxes sur les taxes et votre pouvoir
d'achat qui disparaît
lorsque vous ne vivez pas dans une
grande métropole je veux pour vous les
mêmes avantages que
pour les travailleurs des grandes villes
qui se déplace dans les transports en
commun car ceux qui prennent le bus ou
le métro se font rembourser la moitié de
leurs frais de déplacement par leur
employeur mais rien pour les
automobilistes c'est injuste je veux
rétablir l'égalité entre les urbains et
les ruraux l'égalité entre les
travailleurs des villes bénéficiant des
services publics et les travailleurs des
villes l'oise et
avec lui
les salariés qui n'ont pas de solution
de transport en commun pourront se faire
rembourser la moitié de leurs frais de
carton c'est 40 euros de plus par mois
pour le salarié que les patrons pourront
déduire de leur bénéfice imposable
oui
oui mes amis
nous voulons que le travail paie mieux
nous croyons au mérite nous croyons à
l'effort et c'est pour cela que nous
voulons que chaque travailleur puisse
bénéficier de la richesse qu'il a créé
et pour cela nous voulons repenser notre
manière de distribuer les fruits du
travail
c'était le grand projet économique et
social général de gaulle celui qui
l'attend est de mettre en place
jusqu'aux derniers mois de sa présidence
ce projet était celui de la
participation
la participation c'est faire bénéficier
directement le salarié des succès de son
entreprise la participation c'est la
défense d'une mairie alors je veux que
les salariés puissent toucher une prime
de participation aux bénéfices de leur
entreprise
non
quand l'année a été bonne en les
objectifs ont été atteints et que les
carnets de commandes sont pleins je veux
que les salariés en profitent il n'y
aura plus aucune condition pour
débloquer sa prime de participation
quand on connaît les nombreuses
contraintes qui empêchent aujourd'hui le
salarié d'emprunter avec nous tous les
salariés pour reboucher
immédiatement cette prime sans payer
d'impôt sur le revenu
il
ils feront
ils pourront dépenser cet argent sans
être obligé de l'investir dans un plan
de départ ils pourront enfin profiter
librement toutes les entreprises
pourront verser cette prime sans aucune
charge sociale pas de charge pour
l'entreprise et pas d'apprendre le
salage
la participation est un véritable moyen
pour une entreprise de valoriser le
travail de ses salariés
c'est un moyen de fidéliser ses cadres
d'encourager ses employés galinier les
intérêts de toutes les parties de
l'entreprise c'est cette philosophie
économique qui doit nous inspirer pour
les entreprises qui veulent rémunérer
davantage les ouvriers lance ingénieurs
leurs cadres leurs employés je veux
qu'elles puissent le faire sans être
dissuadés par l'urssaf sans regretter
que la moitié de ce qu'elle donne ait
financé on ne sait quelles dépenses
oui
je les ai déjà dit et je le répète les
salaires nets sont rumba pour les
salariés et les salaires bruts son
propre et le bim pour les chefs
d'entreprise
il nous faut trouver tous les moyens de
résoudre cette équation
augmenter les revenus nets salariés sans
faire exploser le salaire re enrichit un
travailleur sans appauvrir l'entreprise
et pour cela et pour cela mes amis je
vais vous annoncer une nouvelle mesure
c'est une mesure simple et pourtant je
crois que c'est une révolution c'est une
mesure qui va enfin permettre aux
travailleurs de boire son travail
valente et c'est une mesure qui mettra
fin au scandale des salaires trop bas
sur lesquels baisse des charges pour les
impôts les taxes les urssaf brille le
travail des experts les entrepreneurs et
des fourrages les travailleurs je
proposerai la prime 0 j'ai pour 0 tab
pour augmenter notre revenir ainsi à
tous patrons pour accorder une prime
chaque année sans aucune date ni aucune
charge ni patronales ni salariales
cette prime cette prime pourra
représenter jusqu'à trois mois de
salaire n'est 13ème 14ème 15ème mois
sans ça
[Applaudissements]
voilà
voilà voilà ce que je vous propose mes
amis c'est rotax 0 ap toute prime
augmentant leurs revenus des salariés
tout patron pourra récompenser celui qui
travaille celui qui fait des efforts et
vous verrez les salariés pourront alors
travailler davantage pour recevoir cette
nouvelle prime zéro charge
c'est donc une mesure qui permettra de
mieux récompenser le mérite est de
lutter contre les arrêts maladie et
l'absentéisme de qu'on présente qui
coûtent jusqu'à 100 milliards d'euros
chaque année
un chef d'entreprise pourra décider de
verser à ses salariés une prime exonérée
de toute ya 3000 euros de coût pour
l'entreprise 3000 euros dans la proche
du salarié voilà comment pour récompense
le travail le mairie et les
po1
à vous les chefs d'entreprise voilà
comment je vous permettrait d'augmenter
les rémunérations
à vous les cas les employés les ouvriers
les salariés voilà comment nous
augmenterez votre pouvoir d'achat je
voulais dit je ne suis pas comme ces
politiciens dogmatique qui défont
systématiquement ce que leurs
prédécesseurs ont fait si la prime macro
sans charge ni un bon voter pendant le
pot vide a été une bonne chose pourquoi
la limite est à ce point pourquoi
limiter cette prime à 1000 euros pour la
plupart des entreprises je ne veux plus
que l'urssaf dissuade les patrons
d'augmenter les salaires ou de verser
une prime comment valoriser le mérite
comment
comment valoriser le même si lorsqu'un
patron vers 5000 euros de prime un
salarié qui a trimé toute l'année il est
obligé de payer 4000 euros de charges
sociales pour financer un modèle social
aux baisses ouvert au monde entier
voilà ce qui empêche les salariés d'être
payé davantage voilà ce qui empêche de
mieux valoriser le travail c'est cette
folie à laquelle nous voulons montrer
c'est cette folie à laquelle nous
mettrons pour des millions
d'entrepreneurs et de patrons de petites
et moyennes entreprises pour des
millions d'artisans de commerçants et
même de grandes entreprises je donne en
ce temps là possibilité de récompenser
un salarié sans être taxés davantage
rendez vous compte andré picot nous
allons enrichir le travailleur sans
appauvrir l'entreprise c'est une
révolution économique sociales
salariales inédit c'est une immense
mesure de justice sociale et fiscale
voila voila ma vision de l'économie je
ne veux pas je ne veux plus d'un état
qui ne fait que taxer imposé réglementé
fonctionner d'un état qui redistribue
mal et dissuadent les entrepreneurs je
veux un état qui permettent aux salariés
de mieux profiter de la croissance de
leur entreprise c'est une question de
mérite et c'est une question de justice
oui il y à une urgence sociale dans
notre pays qui a pourtant les dépenses
sociales les plus élevées du monde
mais nous avons la solution je dirais
même plus nous sommes la solution
nous sommes
some la solution du mérite du travail et
de la justice
nous sommes la seule solution pour le
véritable progrès social
la reconquête
que nous incarnons ces privilégiés enfin
nos compatriotes qui travaillent la
reconquête que nous voulons c'est
garantir enfreint la réussite à ceux qui
travaillent dur mais combattre
l'assistanat la reconquête nous
défendons c'est lutter contre le grand
remplacement pour lutter contre le grand
déclassement
[Applaudissements]
oui
oui le pouvoir d'achat fait partie des
principales angoisses des français et il
fait aussi partie des principaux piliers
de notre programme mais là encore notre
position est cohérente avec notre vision
de la france oui nous allons redonner
envie d'y croire à tant de français qui
n'y croyaient plus qu'ils en ont assez
de voir leur situation personnelle et
celle de leur pays déclinée oui nous
pensons que demain sera meilleur oui
c'est possible car impossible n'est pas
français
oui
oui nous sommes convaincus que la france
a des stocks que les français ont un
destin son pote qui est là depuis mille
ans et qui a envie d'être là encore
milan alors notre peut voir mes amis
c'est de préserver de cultiver de
transmettre de préserver notre héritage
de cultiver notre art de vivre de
transmettre notre civilisation et pour
cela nous allons avoir besoin de nos
entreprises qu'elles soient prêtes à
produire à innover pour partir à la
conquête du monde nous allons avoir
besoin de français qui vivent bien de
leur travail et qu'ils n'ont plus
l'angoissé des fans mois nous voulons
redevenir ce peuple solide robuste
sierre et plein de confiance en lui
2 contient confort travail de confiance
dans son génie oui oui je veux insuffler
à la france cet esprit de reconquête
nous avons un pays à reconquérir nous
avons le clown au mit à reconquérir rien
ni personne ne nous fera pas maîtriser
notre pays son économie
ces travailleurs est le fruit de leurs
efforts rien ni personne ne nous fera
oublier que nous sommes nés dans la
prospérité qu'elle a éclairé notre passé
et qui nous attend dans l'avenir rien ni
personne ne nous fera abandonner nos
parents nos enfants nos envies nos
ambitions nos projets rien ni personne
ne nous empêchera de vif chez nous et
pour nous il ne nous déclasserons pas il
ne nous soumettrons pas il ne nous
remplacerait pas il faudra nous arrache
hier ils n'y arriveront pas parce qu'on
a
parce que parce que le courage c'est
nous le panache c'est nous
le travail le drapeau qui flotte part
d'histoire c'est nous la nation qui
passent par les yeux c'est nous
l'afer qui refuse de se soumettre
le fier qui n'a plus peur c'est long
en tout cas c'est non vyntra fait les
gens vivent notre travail pit notre
grandeur vivent tous ceux que nous
aimons ils font ce que nous créons
inline et surtout surtout
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
voilà donc
voilà une heure trente plus d'une heure
trente ou 1h30 de discours d'eric
zemmour à lille ce discours va être un
véritable game 'changer de l'île chris
kraus il va remonter de quelques points
j'en suis sûr est-ce que de votre point
de vue chers internautes
c'est simplement
le sentiment de chris kraus ou bien
est-ce que ces sentiments est ce que
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de ce
discours vous l'avait commentée vous
avez des battus on va y revenir dans ce
débrief avec guillaume bernard je
rajoute j'ajoute un que c'est l'après
midi des meetings pendant que eric
zemmour parler et bien le meeting de
marine le pen lui a démarré à reims et
vous pouvez retrouver le
l'événement est le commentaire de
frédéric micheau d'opinion way qui est
aux côtés de vincent rose rompt avec
daphné caravaca et albane boxe sur place
et le journaliste du figaro en charge de
la couverture du rassemblement national
charles sympa nous on est à lille avec
timothée d'hellemmes et maxime laurie
est ce que timothée m'entends
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors oui je vous lance
voilà on va retrouver timothée dans un
instant
[Musique]
c'est ce qui nous a frappés c'est ce qui
vous a marqué dix ans bernard c'est
l'ambiance qui est dans la salle alors
on c'est une ambiance assez
caractéristique je dirais des thèmes
d'un meeting mais j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait effectivement oui la combinaison
je dirais d'une d'une grande attention
de la part du public et puis de l'
enthousiasme à la fin évidemment avec
cette montée crescendo
je crois que
les auditeurs les militantes et moore
étaient eux-mêmes inquiet de ce qu' ils
soient capables de tenir un discours sur
autre chose que sur son prisme
interprétatif habituel qui est
l'immigration et en particulier
l'islamisation or là à l'évidence rond
de nan je dirais a évidemment avoir
toujours cette même ligne directrice il
a abordé un sujet sur lequel jusqu'à
présent il était sinon inaudible du
moins je dirais peu loquace et il l'a
fait un certain nombre je dirais
d'analysés et de propositions qui font
qu'il a semble-t-il combler un vide
après est ce que ces propositions
convaincre ont vraiment des électeurs
comme le dit l'un de nos internautes moi
je serai plus prudent plus prudent que
lui mais en tout cas il a
rempli un vide qui était de montrer que
les diverses insécurité auquel seront
faits auxquels les francs que les
français connaissent auxquels ils sont
confrontés
et bien se tiennent que ce soit la
sécurité physique et matérielle
l'insécurité économique et social et la
sécurité culturelle et morale donc là de
ce point de vue là oui je crois que ce
discours de lille était important pour
eric zemmour et qu'il ne le
manquent pas après vous me laissez
commenté continuer a commenté enfin
si timothée nous entend
donc à lille où il se trouve timothée
est ce que vous m'entendez non timothée
ne me manque pas d qu'ils mentent en ont
le diplôme
exactement prendra rendez sur le web en
mai en direct on est avec vous monsieur
zemmour créé la 10 l'adhésion ans dit
elle 36 alors quand même il y avait pas
mal d'objection également sur le tchat
en tous les cas le chat du figaro
également celui sur youtube et on vous
remercie d'avoir commenté d'avoir réagi
on va justement y revenir mais comme
on me dit que timothée d'hellemmes qui
est l'envoyé spécial du figaro live à
lille grand palais est avec nous et bien
je vais lui donner la parole thimoté la
salle était lé plein et la salle est
elle en train de se vider
oui vincent la salle est en train de se
vider ça c'est une certitude nous le
voyait d'ailleurs d'air mois les
militants qui sont en train de quitter
les lieux
discours d'eric zemmour la salle était
pleine de fait les équipes de ferries
est mort annonce dix mille participants
cet après midi
alors il ya quelques quelques chaises
sont restés vides pendant tout le
discours d'eric zemmour je dirais
peut-être environ 1000 chefs sont restés
vides en revanche je suis allé me
promener un petit peu de vent au niveau
de l'estrade il y avait également à peu
près la même proportion personnes à peu
près mon père salle était debout et qui
me du fait des fins de badauds chaise
donc on peut considérer
la salle a quittés
grosso modo remplissez d'aplistes alors
qu'ils mottet je vous vois à côté d'un
militant l'enjeu pour eric zemmour
s'était cet après midi notamment de
convaincre sur une thématique sur
laquelle ils étaient jugées faibles qui
était la thématique du pouvoir d'achat
est ce que la personne qui a été à côté
de vous a été convaincu au delà de
l'éventuel sympathie qu'elle pouvait
éprouver à l'égard du candidat
justement la question que
causé cet étudiant en droit doncker
aline bonjour merci d'eau
le temps de nous répondre à la question
vous avez et ces combats
par eric zemmour en date la sympathie
que vous avez pour le candidat sur le
thème du pouvoir d'achat bike carrément
j'ai été vraiment j'étais convaincu je
soutiens eric zemmour à 100% je trouve
qu'il a été fait un très bon discours
sur les jeunes sur le pouvoir d'achat et
qu'il a fait tout pour écran qu'il veut
tout faire pour aider les jeunes et
c'est très important alors il ya
certaines mesures qu'il a répétée par
exemple de revenu sur sa mesure qui
consiste à cette bourse à nathalie fait
donc dix mille euros pour chaque
naissance dans les zones rurales est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une bonne
mesure et qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ceux qui disent que c'est une mesure
populiste bah écoutez moi je pense que
zemmour a enfin veut
je veux vraiment développer la france
rurale et je pense que c'est un très bon
point de favoriser la france rurale et
notamment les naissances dans la france
est dans un moment les villages
hourra
on sait pas que c'est par exemple c'est
une mesure populiste
non je ne pense pas que ces mesures
communiste
il ya d'autres mesures par exemple les
allocations familiales allocations
familiales universelles c'est ce cas
d'eczéma propose d'autres candidats le
propose également par exemple valérie
pécresse la candidate des républicains
qu'est ce qui différencie eric zemmour
de valérie pécresse sur le plan de sur
le plan de la fiscalité
sur le pont du pouvoir d'achat peindre
e
pourquoi vous privilégiez eric zemmour à
un autre candidat sur vraiment sur le
sur le pouvoir d'achat
écoutez moi c'est je suis étudiant donc
je gagne pas encore là ma vie en tant
que dans la société
je pense que c'est un sujet qui le
pouvoir d'achat est très important pour
tous les français y compris pour les
jeunes parce que on est enfin il faut
comme disait eric zemmour c'est un point
là pour le pouvoir d'achat c'est ce qui
nous reste en fin de chaque mois et
pourquoi je vote
eric zemmour parce que je pense que
c'est celui qui représente le meilleur
des candidats pour la france laprise
ancien france 2022 et
voilà un peu un peu d'émotion merci en
tout cas pour cette première cette
première réaction ce premier témoignage
vincent la suite à ce discours d'eric
zemmour qui vient de se terminer les
militants d'ailleurs vous le voyez
derrière moi continuent de quitter la
salle la salle qui se vide assez
rapidement elle est déjà quasiment aux
trois quarts vide en tout cas en ce qui
concerne les chaises et on le voit sur
ces images de maxime fleury la sortie
qui est en train voilà beaucoup beaucoup
de monde avec ses en train d'affluer
vers la vers la sortie mais la salle se
vide quand même relativement rapidement
et on voulait se retrouver bien d'autres
d'autres militants éventuellement des
responsables de l'équipe et mouret
effectivement enceinte informations que
l'on cherche depuis tout à l'heure
combien
deux signatures en tous les cas ont été
re coups de promesses de signatures on
était actuellement recueillis par
l'équipe zemmour un internaute nous
disait j'ai pas eu le temps d'ailleurs
d'aller vérifier sur le site du conseil
constitutionnel qui en avait pour
l'instant une cinquantaine qui était
acquise la question pour l'instant c'est
de savoir si au delà de ces 50 de ses 50
qui sont acquises il y à d'autres
promesses de signatures et si le cap des
500 signatures pour eric zemmour est
atteint guillaume bernard on est avec
vous d'autres personnes réagissent
effectivement l'embarras de cet étudiant
sur les sur les dernières questions on
va pas
non mais l'église et dessus
effectivement faut pas surinterpréter
effectivement suite à suite un débat un
meeting mais
est-ce que c'est aussi la preuve que
l'adhésion à eric zemmour elle se fait
pas sur la thématique du pouvoir d'achat
elle se fait sur d'autres thématiques
auxquelles entendu il est bien évident
que eric zemmour est persuadé par
exemple que marine le pen a raté sa
campagne de 2010 est parce qu elle a
voulu parler d'europe déco de mixer et
qu'elle ne s'est pas concentré sur la
marque de fabrique habituelle du front
national du rassemblement national
décidément c'est à dire la sécurité et
l'immigration et que donc lui il pense
que justement il faut coaliser les
forces politiques et
électorale les différentes catégories
sociales sur la question de l'identité
de l'immigration et que les autres
questions sont dans le fond quelque peu
quelque peu subalternes salaire pendant
il est évident qu'il devait intervenir
sur ce sujet parce que pour le coup il
ya quand même un certain nombre de
personnes qui votent pour le
rassemblement national aujourd'hui pour
des questions parfaitement social ave c
les blocs
identifiés par jérôme sainte-marie le
bloc élitaire et le bloc populaire et ce
bloc populaire dont jérôme sainte-marie
pense qu'il est en cours de constitution
mais il se fait notamment sur les
questions économiques et sociales et pas
seulement sur les questions
d'immigration et d'identité alors au
coeur de la du discours d'eric zemmour
aujourd'hui
finalement l'un des premiers l'une des
attaques l'un des angles d attaque du
candidat a été le gaspillage dévoila et
l'inde est le premier axe politique en
tous les cas qu'il eu de mesures qu'il
prendrait dit il c'est de s'attaquer aux
gaspillages d'état est ce que ce genre
de discours peut convaincre un électorat
populaire en particulier le l'électorat
populaire du nord région at il dit qui a
été sinistrée et régions qui
connaît justement beaucoup ce phénomène
d'état redistributif c'est-à-dire
l'allocation de subventions d'être
social et je croise un sens que vous
mettez exactement le doigt sur
le problème c'est à dire que le discours
d'eric zemmour qui est cohérent
intellectuellement parlant ça même si on
n'est pas d'accord et d'écrire eczéma on
ne peut pas lui faire le reproche de ne
pas chercher à défendre quelque chose de
logique mais le problème c'est que son
discours qu'il consiste à dire et pour
pouvoir retrouver du pouvoir d'achat il
faut que les impôts baissent et pour que
les impôts baissent il faut diminuer les
dépenses c'est un discours qui s'adresse
c'est un discours qu'il est audible que
parce qu'ils sont encore en capacité de
travailler capacités personnelles mais
aussi capacités sociales c'est-à-dire
les catégories moyennes qui sont
incontestablement asphyxiée par la
pression fiscale et les catégories
supérieures or il ne faut pas se cacher
que il y à une paupérisation des
catégories
moyenne qui lie à tout un ensemble de
travailleurs qui sont tout simplement
dans des régions où l'emploi industriel
notamment a été totalement sinistré par
les délocalisations
récemment par la mondialisation de
manière plus globale et par conséquent
il est certain que une partie de
l'électorat qui votent pour marine le
pen est bien ne peut pas êtres ne peut
pas se sentir concerné on pouvait se
sentir beaucoup moins concerné par ce
discours là qui est un discours qui
s'adresse encore une fois à ceux qui
sont encore en capacité de savoir
pourquoi elle préfère travailler par
honneur par capacités plutôt que
l'assistanat il y a malheureusement dans
notre pays un certain nombre de
personnes qui se retrouvent sans
alternative qui ne sont pas en capacité
d'être dans l'alternative et ça je
crains pour lui que cet électorat là il
ne soit pas en capacité de le séduire
sur le discours économique peu le
séduire en revanche sur d'autres aspects
en revanche ce discours là il me semble
qu'ils étaient essentiellement destinés
à l'électorat traditionnel rpr et front
national alors là pour le coup je fais
exprès d'utiliser le front national
c'est pas ma langue qui rappe qui
fourche c'est l'électorat rpr et front
national des années 80 et 90 c'est à
dire ceux qui effectivement été sur des
positions alors on va dire libéral
encore qu'elle ne soit pas
nécessairement libéral idéologiquement
parlant mais ils ont pour les libertés
économiques pour l'initiative pour la
baisse des charges etc et là en revanche
c'est vrai que c'était leur lectorat là
il peut essayer d il peut essayer de le
séduire mais est-ce qu'il ne l'a pas
déjà en grande partie séduit c'est ça la
question est ce que cet électorat-là du
rpr qui avait basculé vers le front
national est ce que il n'est pas déjà
retourné chez eric zemmour ça
effectivement on ne le sera que
véritablement le soir des résultats du
premier tour on le reverra et on suivra
ça on va retrouver thimoté
lm qui est donc à lille avec un militant
j'ai même peut-être une première
question parce que je vois que votre
interlocuteur n'a pas de masque timothée
nous non plus on ne respecte les
d'istres ont respecté les distances il
ya des internautes qui demandait s'il y
avait on demandait le pass sanitaires à
l'entrée du meeting on rappelle que en
tout cas oubliez les meetings ne sont
pas soumis à l'obligation du pass
sanitaires
alors oui effectivement je suis avec un
étudiant en école d'ingénieur militants
pro eric zemmour nous remarquons que
vous n'avez pas de vous n'avez pas de
masque est ce qu'un pass sanitaire vous
avez été demandée à l'entrée de ce
meeting alors impasse anita a été
demandée et
je pense que ça reste important de 2 de
garde et de garder quelques quelques
précautions sur sur ce meeting voilà
tout simplement enfin il faut faut
respecter respecter les gens qui ont qui
ont du mal à qui peuvent attraper ce
virus et qu'ils peuvent voilà qui
peuvent en souffrir mais vous on vous a
demandé de flash est ce que nous sommes
nous c'est pas notre cas en tout cas moi
même et notre générique maxime verrons
nous a pas demandé de flasher le qr code
est ce que vous vous a demandé un qr
code à flasher à vrai dire je dois dire
je m'en souviens pas
je crois que non mais
non je crois que non voilà pour cette
première pour cette première question
vincent
je le disais en tout cas en ce qui nous
concerne nous on n'a pas eu de on n'a
pas eu un flash et le qrcode le passé
les terres ne nous a pas été demandé en
revanche le gel hydro alcoolique était
on nous a mis du gel hydroalcoolique sur
la mer on ne pouvait pas passer si on ne
l'accepté pas d'avoir du gel
hydroalcoolique sur les mains et le
passé ni terre n'était pas n'était pas
demandée sur ce sur ce discours de deux
d'eric zemmour au delà de vos sympathie
pour le candidat qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé des propositions du candidat de
reconquête en ce qui concerne le pouvoir
d'achat alors ce que je retiens
principalement c'est qui veut valoriser
le travail
il veut faire en sorte que les français
puissent travailler sans charge sans
voile à pouvoir travailler de manière
libre il veut à débureaucratiser toute
la société et je pense que c'est ce qui
permettrait aux gens de de retrouver
goût au travail je pense que le travail
comme on le dit souvent c'est la santé
et que
c'est par le travail qu'on peut qu'on
peut faire société qu'on peut aider à
participer au bien commun et voilà donc
je pense que c'est
c'est assez pertinent de sa part de
vouloir valoriser le travail est ce
qu'il y à une mesure ce que eric zemmour
a donné quelques mesures concrètes ce
cet après midi et ce qui a une mesure
une ou deux qui vous a particulièrement
frappé qui vous a particulièrement
interpellé en tant que militant oui
alors je dois dire que l'économie n'est
pas mon domaine de prédilection
mais mais là le fait qu'il valorise les
primes qu'ils
qu'il enlève toutes les taxes sur les
primes ça me je pense que ça motive les
travailleurs à fournir à fournir des
efforts pour voilà pour faire grandir
leur entreprise et pour participer comme
je le disais tout à l'heure au bien
commun sur les ralliements et à eric
zemmour il ya eu certains ralliements
récemment et malgré tout dans les
sondages on voit qu eric zemmour ne
progresse pas il continue à stagner
autour de douze ennemis 13% est ce que
vous croyez réellement aux chances de
dérèglement de devenir président de la
république ou est-ce que après tout vous
dites c'est une candidature de
témoignage voilà qu'est ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que vous avez le réel
espoir puis votre candidat devienne
président de la république au mois
d'avril alors je pense qu'ils portent
des idées très intéressantes qu'il est
nécessaire de d'aborder je comprends
tout à fait que certains certains
français ne soit pas en radical d accord
avec lui
mais ceci dit
il en cause quand même des discussions
qu'il est nécessaire je pense d'abord d
après évidemment on peut
partager ou pas son point de vue
et les yonnais ce que vous pensez qu'il
a de réelles chances de l'emporter et
je j'espère
il est vrai que il n'est pas beaucoup
beaucoup de français ne l'apprécient pas
et je pense que c'est dommage d'ailleurs
parce que il porte un vraiment un
discours d'espérance il tend la main à
beaucoup de français donc oui je pense
qu'il a des chances de gagner maintenant
c'est voilà c'est difficile de s'avancer
je pense que les sondages sont peuvent
donner quelques idées mais voilà encore
il faut les prendre avec des pincettes
un dernier petit mot en tant que
militant puisqu'il ya pas mal de
critiques sur eric zemmour on dit que
c'est un candidat populiste nous dit que
c'est un candidat qui est un petit peu
dans l'emporte-pièce et notamment marine
le pen qui dit me voilà nous on veut
nous maintenant on a un discours plus
policé etc c'est moins qu'à 2 2 d'eric
zemmour est ce que vous pensez que ça ça
peut lui causer du tort est ce que vous
pensez que eric zemmour a une réelle
stature présidentielle
je pense que une stature présidentielle
incluant une certaine fermeté donc oui
je pense que eric zemmour a tout en
étant
parfois doux avec avec ceux avec qui ils
parlent a assez de fermeté qui qui
nécessaire pour gouverner la france on
l'a vu en journaliste en polémiste en
historians certains disent qu'il vaut
mieux en économiste qu'un historien
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est faux et
que la france a besoin d'un historien
plus qu'un économiste alors évidemment
il a beaucoup d'économistes derrière lui
ce qui ce qui est rassurant
donc ça ça c'est la c1 penser que je oui
en effet je pense qu'il a il a la
carrure pour être président merci
beaucoup voilà vincent pour ce deuxième
témoignage d'un militant pro eric
zemmour qui semble plutôt convaincu par
par le discours de son candidat cet
après midi merci beaucoup timothée
peut-être une petite une première
question une autre question thimoté
c'était des personnes dans le chat qui
demandez qui disait que l'assistance
était assez jeune on vous a entendu
interrogé deux étudiants d'autres
demandent qu'on si on peut interroger
d'autres étudiants quand je vois l'état
de la salle ça va être un petit peu
compliqué d'aller encore interviewé du
monde mais est ce que cette assistance
elle était
majoritairement jeunes ou bien est ce
que l a regroupé tous les âges
non je vous confirme vincent est
effectivement une assistance à ces
jeunes c'est quelque chose également
qu'il nous a qui nous a frappés beaucoup
d'étudiants et d'ailleurs ça se voit
dans le profil des personnes que j'ai
interviewé beaucoup d'étudiants
et voilà il ya aussi il n'y a pas
beaucoup de familles ou pas beaucoup de
retraités de fête et ça se voit assez
facilement je ne sais pas si on va
réussir en avoir d'autres parce que vous
le voyez sur ces images la salle est
déjà plus que trois quarts vide mais je
vous confirme effectivement une
assistance clairement clairement à ces
jeunes difficile à dire à la louche mais
c'est vrai que je pense que les 20 35
ans sont sont assez majoritairement
représentés
merci timothée pour pour ses réponses on
vous retrouve encore une fois juste
peut-être ce sera l'occasion pour vous
d'aller voir vers l'extérieur s'il ya
une ambiance particulière en tous les
cas et on conclura avec vous
lors de cette précédente prochaine
intervention peut-être au retour de
cette es
deux sets de ce plateau
guillaume peut-être on va faire
l'inventaire des mesures qui ont été
annoncées quand même par eric zemmour
parce qu'il y en a certaines la mesure
dans tous les cas celle sur laquelle il
a le plus insisté c'est la possibilité
de verser jusqu'à 3 mois de salaires
sous forme de prime une prime exonérée
de toute charge une prime zéro charge
oui c'est à dire que là pour le coup il
me semble que de la même manière qu'il
veut reprendre la la la mesure de
sarkozy sur l'exonération des charges
sur les heures supplémentaires
il veut favoriser la possibilité des
personnes de s'engager dans le travail
d'être motivés et de travailler la seule
chose évidemment c'est que ça
suppose que l'employeur soit si j'ose
dire loyal vis-à-vis de ses salariés
qu'ils reconnaissent la qualité qu'il
reconnaisse l'engagement la motivation
est là et la réussite c'est vrai que
j'aurais alors c'est un commentaire je
les dires du personnel que politique il
me semble que le fait que les salaires
chargés ou non et en particulier les
moins chargées possible pour qu'ils
soient les plus rentable possible pour
l'entreprise que l'augmentation des
salaires me paraît plus important que le
fait de toucher des primes voilà mais il
est bien certain que il y a dans le raid
symboliquement généralement on est plus
sensible à une augmentation de salaire
et assure une augmentation de prix
assure ne serait ce que parce que le
salaire va contribuer à et bien
vos revenus lors de la période de la
retraite mais je dirais que avec d'un
côté je dirais une lutte contre
l'immigration la préférence nationale
d'un côté et de l'autre côté le fait de
valoriser le travail au détriment de
l'assistanat il a essayé dans son
discours encore une fois je ne sais pas
ce que ça va donner du point de vue
électoral mais il a essayé de je dirais
de satisfaire et de capter je dirais les
les différents types d'électorat les
différents segments électoraux qui sont
à droite et qu'il ne souhaite évidemment
rassembler est ce que c'est ce sous ce
prisme en tout cas ce que le fait
d'avoir proposé un remboursement de 50 %
des frais occasionnés par
l'usagé de son véhicule pour aller
travailler va dans ce sens également
ça va en tout cas dans une
volonté et ce alors là pour le coup je
crois 2
ne pas traiter de manière inégalitaire
les habitants de la france périphérique
et les habitants des métropoles mais là
pour le coup évidemment le sait bien
dans les métropoles il y a des
transports en commun qui sont
utilisables et assez facilement
utilisables sont pas forcément agréable
à utiliser
enfin ils sont utilisables tandis que
dans la france périphérique un de
christophe guilluy c'est à dire le
périurbain les petites villes etc il est
bien évident que les français pour aller
travailler ont besoin de leur automobile
est donc là je crois que là pour le coup
c'était une mesure est une proposition
13 anti écologiste où on tire non pas
écologie mais anti europe ecologie les
verts si vous si si si si vous gardez
telle expression et une volonté de
réunifier la france compterait gilet
jaune dans absolument il a utilisé une
des formules les plus importantes
d'ailleurs mais alors pour le coup il
n'est pas le seul un marine le pen aussi
le fait de vouloir vivre de son travail
vous l'a dit vivre dignement de ce
travail plutôt que de vivre sous
assistance ça c'est très clair c'était
typique des gilet jaune c'est à dire les
petits commerçants les petits artisans
les petits entrepreneurs avec leurs
propres salariés qui étaient sur les
ronds points on dit également que ça
peut être un discours qui justement peu
s'adresser à un électorat plutôt de
sensibilité rpr comme on disait front
national des années 80 90 est ce que
justement l'hommage rendu à nicolas
sarkozy au nicolas sarkozy de 2007 avec
la fameuse formule travailler plus pour
gagner plus avec exonération là encore
des des charges supplémentaires sur les
terres de martine aubry sur la terre de
la dame des 35 heures et 5 heures et
également à
délibérer adresse qu un discours mais
qui peut justement séduire là pour le
coup plutôt un lectorat et l'air oui je
crois que c'est ce qu'il a essayé de
faire vous savez
là quoi doit on en parle depuis le début
de l'après-midi un
la quadrature du cercle pour eric
zemmour pour que sa candidature ne soit
pas un échec c'est qu'il faut qu'ils
contribuent à la recomposition du
spectre politique que donc ils soient
générés qui note qu'il ne soit pas dans
le fond le fossoyeur de la droite
nationale parce qu'on le sait très bien
le risque le scénario catastrophe
l'accident industriel c'est que ni lui
ni marine le pen ne soit au second tour
la présidentielle et quand je dis au
second tour que dis je devrais même dire
dès le premier tour parce que vont-ils
avoir l'un et l'autre 500 signatures
chacun bon donc l'énorme risque qu'il
prend au regard générer de l'histoire
c'est un bien grand mot mais enfin il le
prend quand même c'est le fait de
réussir la recomposition or pour réussir
cette recomposition il ne faut pas qu'il
soit simplement un substitut à marine le
pen il faut qu'ils élargissent le
spectre politique l'espace politique de
la droite et de la droite nationale eh
bien il est bien évident que aujourd'hui
il a besoin de
radicalisé l'électorat et l'air de le
reconquérir et pas simplement je dirais
d'aller siphonner l'électorat front
national parce que dans ce cas là à quoi
aurait servi effectivement l'aventuré
mauriste donc c'est vrai que sur le fait
de parler de prime des fils qu'elle s'en
charge le fait de parler de
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires là pour le coup
effectivement il s'il est clair qu'il
est sèye d'agglutiner à un électorat qui
est peut-être plus un ancien électorat
rpr devenu front national d'essayer
d'agglutiner l'actuel électorat et l'air
quel chef d'entreprise disposent en
trésorerie de trois mois de salaire
c'est ce que nous dit notamment cet
internaute ici si le salarié a contribué
j'imagine à augmenter le chiffre
d'affaires s'est pour cela qu'il va
toucher une prime j'imagine que s'il n'y
a pas d'augmentation du chiffre et des
marges il n'y aura pas deux il y aura
pas de primes versées c'est évident en
tous les cas il ya pas mal de débats
alors on se parle peut-être une un point
qui est marquée en lacets pour sa part
sa rivale marine le pen vous le voyez
pas mais vous pouvez le voir si dans le
l'autre flux qui est actuellement
diffusée sur le site du figaro viktor
orban
un clip de viktor orban est diffusée par
par les équipes de marine le pen arras
petit coup dur pour zemmour là il est
bien évident que c'est un soutien direct
ou indirect je ne sais pas jusqu'à quel
point le premier ministre hongrois se
mouiller il est bien évident que ça pèse
beaucoup plus que le fait qu' un ou deux
conseillers régionaux ou un ou deux
députés européens et rennes soit passé
chez zemmour ça c'est oui là pour le
coup c'est évident pour autant ce que ça
peut se traduire en termes de votre
commande le pas nécessairement mais
encore une fois vous savez on est dans
le symbole là pour le coup on est
vraiment dans le symbole parce qu'on a
dit ce soir qu'il y avait et bien
gilbert collard ou jérôme rivière mais
c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas de nouvelles
personnalités vous l'avez vous même
remarque fort dans le compare les
valeurs thierry mariani quand même lui
un transfuge mc lain anglicane prenez la
parole à reims et encore il est fidèle à
marie le pen bon donc donc si vous
voulez il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens qui
de l air de figure et l'eire qui
soutiennent eric zemmour et puis
évidemment marine le pen a très
clairement coupé l'herbe sous le pied de
marion maréchal si tenté que un jour
elle devait officiellement soutenir eric
zemmour ça ne serait plus une nouvelle
ça serait juste une confirmation de
quelque chose que l'on sait déjà et donc
par conséquent pour le coup marine le
pen à la stratégiquement plutôt bien
joué médiatiquement médiatiquement
parlant alors on va retourner justement
à lille où un des responsables de
l'équipe de la campagne d'eric zemmour
est aux côtés de timothée d'hellemmes
peut-être timothée donc deux questions à
votre interlocuteur d'abord sur les
rangs le terme de signature on cherche
toujours et
peut-être une réaction à ce message que
viktor orban de messages de soutien que
viktor orban vient d'adresser à marine
le pen
oui tout à fait vincent avec denis ciel
tic ça tombe bien c'est le responsable
des parrainages d'eric zemmour on se
posait la question où on est eric
zemmour sur les sur les promesses de
parrainages là la réponse de dénis
sciatique jérémy combien combien de
parrainage revendiquez-vous aujourd'hui
alors dernière fois qu'on a communiqué
c'était la semaine dernière et on avait
passé la barre des 450 parrainages donc
il faut faire attention quand on parle
de parrainage on parle de promesses de
parrainages qu'on est à 450 promesses
dernière fois qu'on a communiqué le
chiffre un peu évolué depuis et on reste
plutôt vigilant parce que vous savez
comme il ya toujours des déperditions
entre les parrainages qui sont promis
les parrainages effectivement reçu au
conseil constitutionnel on vise plutôt
600 voire 650 promesses donc on est
optimiste sur le fait qu'on les
obtiendra mais vigilant parce que la
route est encore longue
450 promesses de parrainages vous
espérez six ans quels sont vos délais
est ce que vous vous dites dans deux
semaines on veut avoir temps est-ce
qu'il ya certaines voilà des délais que
vous vous êtes fixé bien sûr le 4 mars
le conseil constitutionnel arrête la
réception des parrainages et donc il
faut que au 4 mars on est a minima 500
parrainages effectivement reçu donc
c'est ça notre limite et c'est ça si
vous voulez la barrière qu'il faudra
franchir à ce moment là alors une
question plus générale sur la non marine
le pen effet son meeting ans - reims
meeting qui veulent débuter une vidéo de
viktor orban a été diffusée viktor orban
le président hongrois le premier
ministre hongrois pardon qui annonce
soutenir la candidate du rassemblement
national c'est un coup dur pour eric
zemmour
non je dirais pas que c'est un coup dur
vous savez nous on est toujours dans
cette même logique après évidemment
c'est une campagne aura des soutiens il
y aura des gens qui soutiendront marine
le pen nôtre qui soutiennent eric
zemmour maintenant nous ce qu'on dit
c'est qu'on va faire l'union des droites
parce qu'on est les seuls à pouvoir la
faire cette union l'ailé à l'air ne
feront pas le trajet jusqu aux arènes et
inversement le à rennes ne fera pas le
trajet jusqu'au à l'air on dit que nous
on a des gens du rn et des gens du lr et
cette union et droite on est en train de
la constituent et regarder les gens dans
la salle je suis un ancien n je suis un
ancien et leur pardon il ya des anciens
et rennes voilà on fait cette union
maintenant que d'autres soutiennent
marine le pen que d'autres soutiennent à
l'inalco
ça fait partie de la campagne ça nous
impacte en réalité peu il y a un nom
auquel qui revient régulièrement ces
temps ci c'est marion maréchal on se
demander d'ailleurs si elle serait là
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas été le cas est ce
que vous espérez son ralliement dans les
prochains jours eh ben je vais vous
répondre dans la même logique que la
réponse précédente ont fait l'union des
droites donc on a évidemment envie que
toutes les personnalités de droite nous
rejoignent qui seront issues du à rennes
qu'ils soient issus de l air et donc oui
l'arrivée de mario ce serait un super
coup médiatique on serait ravis et ça
représenterait quelque chose
politiquement pour autant c'est pas non
plus et marion là à challes qui va voter
6 millions de fois donc cette union faut
qu'on la fasse dans les urnes et si des
gens nous rallions sera évidemment ravi
et si c'est marion particulièrement est
ce que vous attendez d'autres
ralliements or mario maréchal parce que
j'imagine que il ya des rallyes pas du
jour au lendemain et des pourparlers
vous devez être en contact avec certains
élus peut-être du rassemblement national
des républicains est ce que vous
attendez des ralliements dans les
prochains jours
soyez patient vous verrez bien vous
verrez bien ce que les prochains jours
et les prochaines semaines nous réserve
en attendant je le répète et je le
répèterai toujours on fait du non à
droite nous c'est ce qu'on martèle
l'union donc tous les ralliements doute
qu'il se voit dès lors qu'ils sont
d'accord sur le constat est d'accord sur
une proposition c'est à dire dès lors
qu'ils sont de droite seront les
bienvenus
timothée merci beaucoup d'ennemis
sciatique voilà vincent pour ce nouveau
témoignage wiimote et reid ont rattrapé
par denis st sic parce qu'il ya une
question quand même qu'on se pose
peut-être mais vous allez le rattraper
s'il est bien à côté de vous les liens à
côté des taux il revient il revient il
est de retour alors ce qu'on remarque
quand même sur les ralliements c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de ralliement et
rennes
mais cette après midi on a vu qu'un
ralliement lr c'était certes de choix
qui était guillaume pelletier est-ce
qu'il ya pas un peu de difficulté à
rallier de ce que tu es là et à rallier
des élus et l'air
oui c'est vrai initiatique on constate
que qu'il ya beaucoup de ralliement il
ya un certain nombre en tout cas de
ralliement du rassemblement national
récemment
vous parlez de l'union des droites pour
l'instant ça te penches beaucoup du côté
du r n du côté de l air il ya un
ralliement importance le big game
pelletier l'ancien numéro deux du parti
mais enfin malgré tout est ce que vous
vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez est ce
que vous vous pensez que vous pouvez
encore aller chercher également des gens
du rassemblement national du lr vous les
intérêts des républicains on peut aller
chercher des gens aux élèves et aux
arènes et je vais vous dire vous m'avez
parlé de guillaume pelletier évidemment
ancien numéro deux du parti c'est une
comme on dit une prise de guerre
politique importante mais des alertes on
en a des centaines on en a des milliers
et ils sont ici ils sont dans les salles
les nerfs ils rejoignent par centaines
par milliers tous les jours ce sont pas
des élus non mais c'est ce que je vous
ai dit à la fois précédente à la fin
ceux qui vont aller voter ceux qui vont
aller exprimée dans les urnes leur envie
et leur ambition pour la france ça n'est
pas guillaume pelletier ça n'est pas
marion maréchal ou en tout cas si
hauteur d'une voix et donc les salaires
nous rejoignent déjà énormément
maintenant à la question de savoir est
ce qu'il y aura des prises de guerre
importantes qui viennent de chez les
républicains là encore soyez patients et
nous verrons bien est ce qu'il n'ya pas
un danger malgré tout parce qu'on voit
qu'il ya des conseillers régionaux des
conseillers départementaux du
rassemblement national qui sont en train
d'affluer effectivement c'est un fait
vers eric zemmour mais peut-être que ce
sont des personnes qui n'ont pas obtenu
par exemple une investitures aux
législatives qui espère l'obtenir avec
eric zemmour et qui skie qui font cela
par par pure stratégie alors ça c'est
quelque chose qui a été beaucoup dit on
a beaucoup dit en fait stratégiquement
les ralliements ne se font pas par
conviction ils se font uniquement par
stratégie je pense que si on dit ça il
faut aussi être cohérent tout le monde
nous rabâche à longueur de journée que
marine le pen est largement devant nous
dans les sondages alors quel intérêt
aurait-il à nous rejoindre puisque
précisément il était dans un parti qui
était donné devant eric zemmour
peut-être parce que marine le pen ne
leur donne pas l'investiture aux
législatives dans quatre mois mais vous
savez moi je suis pas dans la tambouille
politique je suis pas dans mais vraiment
je dire c'est que ça ne m'intéresse pas
de savoir quels sont les accords de
partie au rassemblement national quelles
sont les accords de partie nous on fait
notre union on trace notre route que
nous rejoignent qu'ils veuillent
maintenant on verra bien et on n'est pas
dans la négociation et ce qui a été dit
récemment sur les achats des lieux qui
aurait été fait c'est n'importe quoi
évidemment on n'a même pas encore de
commission nationale d'investiture on
verra bien je pense que les gens qui
nous rejoindre ils le font surtout par
conviction parce qu'ils ont compris que
madame le pen ne peut pas gagner
voilà merci à nouveau déni sciatique je
rappelle que vous êtes responsable des
parrainages pour campagne d'eric zemmour
merci beaucoup thimoté on fera un
dernier point avec vous avant ce avant
de se quitter
effectivement à reims le meeting de
marine le pen comme est en train de
compte continuent certes mais on vient
de voir louis aliot est apparemment
marine le pen va parler d'un instant à
l'autre et vous pourrez également le
suivre ce soir en direct
deux points peut-être puisqu'on parle de
marine le pen puisqu'on parle également